after nearly 20 years
it is officially the end of the afghan
war as declared by the united states
i don't think it's fair to say that the
the the war is officially over in a
certain sense because there's still
going to be very serious conflict
between warring factions
there are still americans being left
behind
many people are criticizing joe biden
because he promised this wouldn't be the
case and now they're saying it will be
the case there's a lot of there's a lot
to discuss there
and i i do think we're dealing with some
very serious problems and obviously a
very serious crisis
but
i'm not convinced you know it's fair to
say that the us has finally ended the
war so much as they just abruptly left
mid-evacuation because the taliban has
overrun the kabul airport and they can
no longer maintain the position
so sure the war is over and a a
resounding defeat that will lead to
chaos and i'll tell you when you see
these videos taliban flying helicopters
walking through the airports
do you think they will be able to
maintain that infrastructure and that
economy no
i think afghanistan is going to start to
look like syria really soon but far be
it from me to actually
be an expert i mean to act like i'm an
expert on this
we are but humble internet people
complaining about things and we've not
been over there so we definitely you
know we've had some some veterans in the
past but we'll talk about the best of
our abilities because certainly we're
allowed to have opinions but i want to
make sure that's clear i don't think
anyone here is going to pretend to be an
expert having deployed or actually
experience any of this stuff so
take it with a grain of salt there's a
lot of other stuff we can talk about too
which we will get into but uh we got to
talk about afghanistan joining us today
is the wonderful libby emins hi do you
want to introduce yourself i'm libby
emmons i'm the editor-in-chief with the
post-millennial glad to be here right on
welcome back thanks sup libby how's it
going i'm concerned about this afghan
i'm concerned a couple things one is the
way that it's been framed that we
completed the withdrawal when it looks
like we just stopped not it didn't look
like anything got completed it just
ended with this what seems like an
arbitrary out date of the 31st i don't
understand why he would
rush things out leave all this equipment
behind and leave our allies the leaving
of the equipment behind i think is uh
that's pretty egregious also the
shuttering of the air force base instead
of um keeping that open and not having
to go through the civilian airport that
seems like that was really poorly
thought out as well a lot of people are
saying it feels intentional
and feels is different from it is
but uh people have their opinions so you
know
i wonder that it's really intentional or
that it was just sheer incompetence
which is sort of what i'm leading
leaning towards i don't know we'll we'll
talk about it because i don't know if i
agree okay yeah we'll talk about it
especially after trump's latest comments
yeah oh those are good oh yeah
well let me uh before i get something to
say
lydia
yeah i was like what's next what's gonna
happen next i cannot make up my mind of
this incompetence or malice um it's
always kind of a
flip of the coin with the biden
administration i'm hoping it's
incompetence but the sheer volume of
stuff that we left there for our actual
enemies is really disheartening
yeah it could be
abject failure could be before we get
started we'll we'll get another story uh
all these stories go to timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive segments from the tim cast irl
podcast of course we'll have one of
those members only segments coming up
around 11 pm or so tonight as well as an
advertisement free experience and all of
our amazing fierce and independent
journalism and uh i'll let me tell you
we have a story from this morning
cassandra fairbanks investigating there
was a truck carrying modern vaccines
that crashed and hazmat came out
airspace was shut down cleanup crews
working for 21 hours reports that there
was a waterway nearby
and we're we're digging into the story
and it looks like everything's fine it
was a shipment headed to ghana for a
donation and the hhs says that they've
recovered all the vaccines so it wasn't
spilled but a lot of people were
speculating especially in the areas in
west virginia why hazmat came out so
it's an interesting story and it just
goes to show the the journalism that we
are doing and i think you know initially
the story sounds much more exciting you
read into it and you're like okay this
was serious but but check out the news
we've got at timcast.com we've got real
journalists we're hiring more people
every day check that out don't forget to
like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
right now smash that share button take
the url put it wherever you can if you
really enjoy what we do let's uh let's
jump into this first big story we've got
the the lead from daily mail pentagon
confirms the last u.s troops and
evacuation flights have left afghanistan
just after midnight in kabul taliban
take control of airport and celebrate
with gunfire as 20-year war ends
there's there's so much to go through
first of all really is you know ian you
just mentioned in the intro that it
doesn't feel like they've completed the
withdrawal they just stopped withdrawing
like stopped evacuating people and just
bounced out yeah the way this even the
statement this title that you just read
off is phrase is that the last american
troops left is that the last ones that
are going to be leaving or gone now or
is that the last of all of them and then
they're not clear i still i don't know
if people they're very intentionally not
clear they won't let you know how many
americans are left behind they won't let
you know if they
decided to stay on purpose or
if they just didn't get in contact with
these people and then you've also seen
in the past like week or two you've seen
um
people saying on twitter like i let
somebody use my whatsapp to get a visa
at one point and now i'm getting
messages via whatsapp on their behalf
are they getting the messages or am i
just getting the messages you know these
kinds of things so it's really very
peculiar and it's hard to have any idea
what's going on the administration is um
not being transparent about it at all
and you can see that in the questioning
that they've been uh the questions
they've been taking and what's up with
this whatsapp thing someone let's
yeah or maybe it was uh i think it was
actually an email so a person put on
twitter i wish i had it
but it was one of these things that's on
twitter so it's not like you can figure
out exactly what the truth is
and the amount of things that i've been
getting from people on twitter that are
like here's video
of a bunch of people getting shot inside
the kabul airport and it's like you know
i track through that person i attracted
that person to track through everybody
and then you eventually talk to someone
who is unwilling to go on the record and
you're like okay well this story is not
going to ever get out if i can't verify
who these people are and what's going on
so yeah it was somebody had said i let a
friend use my email address to receive
visa information i'm getting
notifications now about how it's time to
leave afghanistan are they getting these
notifications as well
so
i don't think it's fair to say the war
is over
because
uh well unless the press just stops
covering it entirely now and says yay
biden you did it that's clapping what
did i think the atlantic wrote the
article or was in the atlantic that
biden deserves credit not criticism i'm
like no he deserves criticism but uh the
reason i say it's not over is there
still i mean at least estimates here
from the daily mail 100 to 200 americans
are still in afghanistan as well as our
afghan allies right so do you think that
in the coming days that we're going to
hear news about american hostages i've
been wondering about this as well if
we're going to have repeats of these
kind of videos that we that we saw
previously you know these beheading
videos these hostage videos what's going
to happen with that there were um there
was a clip that came out over the
weekend it was uh taliban soldiers in a
tv studio with a tv anchor and the
anchor was saying what the taliban told
them to say
you know where everything's going great
i don't think we have any idea what's
going on and
the fact that we were engaged in a war
for this long in a place that has
destroyed empires before us was already
absurd
yeah that one i find particularly
humorous that people you know have
mentioned hey all of these empires kind
of faltered after afghanistan fiasco but
i'll tell you i'll tell you back to the
point about the war not being over
i'm watching this video clip of the
taliban walking through the airport and
there's like helicopters and planes it's
not just the military equipment they
received it's the civilian equipment
that's left behind by those evacuating
right that's all resources trucks
there's something like 40 000 suvs they
received now i'll tell you why it's not
over you think the taliban
coming in i don't care if it's the
taliban or any any uh government
honestly although the taliban would be
markedly worse you think they're gonna
be able to maintain the power they're
gonna be able to maintain the
infrastructure the economy the natural
resources
yeah homes are gonna lose electricity
overnight how many days do we have until
also the power goes out well also
they're already fighting with uh they
have ideological battles with this
other terrorist organization right now
yeah there was actually a clip um i
don't know i hope i didn't tell you guys
this already
um but jack kerouac went on the william
f buckley show in uh i guess the 60s or
70s whenever it was and uh kerouac said
that he thought the vietnam war was a
conspiracy between the north vietnamese
and the south vietnamese who in his
words were cousins to get a lot of jeeps
in the country
and buckley said well you know i don't
think it went too well for them and
kerouac said i don't know they got a lot
of jeeps yeah
so well they've got a lot of
equipment have you seen the before and
after footage from like idlib or uh
aleppo you know in syria and things like
that oh yeah i mean that was a while ago
a while ago for sure i remember you know
you're looking at these at these photos
particularly like aleppo and it's and
it's amazing this beautiful city and
there's like the colors over saturated
because people are trying to purposely
evoke emotion and but you see the trees
you see the buildings the people and
then it's like the syrian civil war it's
rubble it's brown rubble
i don't know if it's gonna get that bad
in afghanistan necessarily but i i
person my personal opinion which is
based off of just what we're seeing
right now and a lot of things could
change because i can't see the future i
think it might get to that point you you
are you have no clear command structure
it's it's a group of people who are
fighting against the us and now sure
sure let me say this you have some
command structure right there's people
who are in charge
but in order to maintain a country and
let alone a city you need
massive managerial infrastructure which
they do not have so all of a sudden
you're going to have some dude and he's
going to be at a factory that makes i
don't know you know plastic lids or
something whatever they might need and
he's going to be like i don't know where
any of this stuff comes from and he's
going to go to the guy who works there
and says oh we order from this other
company but no one's there right now or
something like that the power company
people are going to leave
already yeah things are going to shut
down the guy who ran their central bank
fled right so now there's no like as
much as i don't like central banking
they're still like the system has been
gutted from the inside so what's gonna
happen where are people with no food
people are gonna go nuts and it's gonna
start breaking down and it's gonna get
brutal it does beg the question
what is america's responsibility to
nations that can't handle their own
governance uh we certainly stepped in in
europe all over the place but is that
the kind of thing that
people want from us and other countries
i think it's pretty clear that the
people in afghanistan don't want that
they don't want the us determining their
government structure or you know any of
that any of that kind of stuff so and
what is the i saw another um
i wish i could remember exactly who this
was i'm sorry that i can't but i saw
somebody else who was talking about how
um america really is falling apart
itself at this point how can we take in
some 200 000
uh
afghan refugees
who knows how well they've been vetted
we have people pouring across the
southern border we don't have any
control over that we have governors
fighting with the president over the
sovereignty of their own states and the
sovereignty of american borders
we can't properly educate our children
we can't figure out a cohesive strategy
for dealing with you know a global
pandemic that we have taken
responsibility for globally as well as
nationally what is it that we think
we're doing you know it's like we
constantly are talking about how much we
hate ourselves and how we are the worst
oppressors and we're you know this
privileged horrible bratty country but
we also take on everybody else's
problems and as much as the left will
talk about american exceptionalism being
a problem they're the most american
exceptionalist of all they think that we
can go out there smack ourselves in the
face wear hate hair shirts and still
save the world
and that's what they expect
it's very weird to watch
yeah
i feel like uh
this war thing in afghanistan which is
never actually it's not a real war it
was never declared by congress it was
just a military action and it was only
to get bin laden there was no taliban
involved in any of this in the beginning
right taliban formed around it and then
then it was isis then it was al qaeda or
it was al qaeda in the beginning well
let's see let's slow down taliban was
1994. okay so it's been around forever
so i guess you know people different
names different places no the taliban
formed out of the out of the mujahideen
and they there was an afghan civil war
that was like expanding gaining more
power and then the us is like we're
gonna go in and get them well we went in
to get al qaeda to get uh osama bin
laden and then that that got happened
they after a couple years and then they
stayed four years yeah after a decade
after and then the real reason we went
and came out was to build that country
as a in the eyes of america and get its
resources
uh
well that faltered we had no no
justification to fight i mean
it's not to fight the taliban we were
never there to fight the taliban right
so that that is not something we will
ever it was look it was it was
colonization they call it nation
building i'm like yeah yeah yeah it's
colonized yeah it was colonizing not i'm
not saying that from some leftist
college blue haired perspective of like
they're colonizers no it's like
literally like it's actually what it is
yeah the only problem with colonization
is when it fails
i guess there's
there's problems with colonization how
would you feel if china colonized new
york city
i think it'd be worse if they did a bad
job of it frankly it'd be bad no matter
what yeah it would be terrible no matter
what sure i guess i guess if china came
in and all of a sudden restored
everyone's civil rights i would say
western colonization is specifically bad
when it fails but i don't think you know
i think there's an argument to be made
that western colonization has actually
been
globally good
you know i'm of the opinion that we
should at this point i mean to a certain
extent i would agree obviously
but i i'm also of the opinion of like
maybe we should mind our own business
especially at this point i feel that way
as well and i also feel that way in
terms of uh nations that clearly don't
have any interest
in
in what we have to offer well there was
a poll i saw of a of a bunch of
different countries pertaining to islam
and when it came to afghanistan
these people did not share our values in
any way
there were people who were
like i'll put i'll put it bluntly we we
can sit here and say hey look it was
better with americans there because of
freedoms and economics but these people
genuinely hate
you know our way of living they they're
they're very very faith-based they're
very very tribal like literal literal
tribes right actually and there was a
poll where i think like a very large
percentage thought the death for i'm
sorry the the punishment for apostasy is
death like we don't have those things
and so we enter this country very
different way of living very different
clothes much much more advanced weapons
and we tell them from now on you live
the way we tell you naturally they're
not happy with that they're still not
happy with that
well and they shouldn't be uh you know
there's also this issue of how can you
bring you can't bring democracy and this
kind of liberty to a populist that
doesn't want it themselves
you know you can't just force that on
people because
that's like the thing you're saying
you're not gonna do and then you're
doing it in order to get them to
live your way that's not effective but
let's talk about the the the more um
what's the right word terrifying results
of everything we've done in this
i'm gonna say it and people might get
mad it actually is a kind of funny video
as much as it is horrifying now i'm
scared taliban appear to fly u.s
blackhawk helicopters over kandahar the
afghan air force reportedly had 167
operational aircraft including 33
blackhawk attack helicopters before the
taliban took over and there's a video
you may have seen it of the taliban
literally flying around in blackhawks
there's like a guy hanging from it and
there's this one this one twitter
account of the taliban they're tweeting
like trying out our new weapons and
stuff like this the us
just gave one of the most advanced
militaries
not an air force and ground forces
to
ideological extremists
who who beat us back with basically
rocks and sticks that's that's that's
the amazing thing like what's the goal
of the americans like how can we funnel
a bunch of weapons to these people
it was we're gonna leave these weapons
for the afghani allies it really was but
we're gonna strip all their support out
and they're just gonna figure it out and
then the afghani allies were like uh no
we're not because we can't but we also
gave them we also gave all those afghan
allies the option of leaving right i
mean we facilitated in the past couple
of weeks or whatever we facilitated a
massive brain drain from that country
how do we expect it to ever stand up for
itself after we basically said to all of
the educated people there why don't you
just come here why don't you abandon
your responsibility to your own nation
and come to a nation that we're already
destroying
that's that's that's really the craziest
thing to me seeing so many people be
like i don't care about this place i'm
leaving right you know
okay why would we
why were we trying to help a nation
where the peop the brightest people in
the country didn't
care about it because they were winning
no no no no yeah yeah yeah i was gonna
say uh these people
were not raised you know a lot of them
are young like the one guy who who got
on the plane and then died i think he
was what 19 years old right the soccer
player so he was born into occupation
right he has no sense of country no
community so when it all comes crashing
down he's like that's what i recognize
and i don't know what that is so i'm
going with that right so the united
states did a very very poor job of of
culture building and you know what's
funny well we shouldn't be culture
building somebody else's culture well no
no no for sure we shouldn't have been in
there in the first place
the point is
if you want an operation like this to be
successful to like create a stable
country whatever you've got to give
people stories and things to rally
around and victories and and some like
you know we have this story of the of
the writing of the star-spangled banner
where like the bombs are exploding and
then every time a bomb blasts you could
see the flag just as the light of the
explosions and then when they came back
to the fort what did they find the dead
bodies of the american soldiers who were
running in and holding the flag up and
their bodies formed the base that kept
those are the stories that people are
like a shed a tear like yes we did it
they don't have any of that we even have
cultural stories though i mean if you
think about it uh during the cold war
you know the ussr was our big enemy and
how did we infiltrate the ussr we you
know americans and
europeans would go there with suitcases
full of blue jeans and beetles tapes
yeah we we infiltrated culture from the
bottom and from the side and from the
angle they make the blue jeans illegal
you'll literally be killed in public if
you're listening to music in public and
you know i think that that's something
that america forgets is our best
offerings are not our you know
administrative level
things our best offerings are our
culture and we are undermining that too
at every
turn in the united states we are
undermining our own culture it's falling
apart
i think for the most part uh the
uniparty is absolutely to blame these
people have no idea how countries are
run politics is downstream from culture
yeah and so the republicans clearly do
not understand this when they're like we
got so many judges in yeah and then the
judges are like political pressures
forced me to go in the direction of
mainstream culture also once you're in
court you lost it doesn't matter what
the victory is i got to say
this 21st century war because this is to
both the points you guys are making with
the new age of military the way it's
done with the internet you don't send
troops to a country nation building you
don't take put a soldier on every block
and every window so that they can't get
from place to place you basically are
controlling the system because they have
facebook groups they can coordinate on
the internet now putting troops in a
foreign country to nation build is not
the tactic anymore and if anything that
i've learned from the vets that are
coming back there it's that you did not
fight in vain you fought to teach us
that in a modern war we cannot be
putting boots on the ground to build
nations it has to be through the
internet except when you can't get
internet in there either because of the
mountainous regions of the country or
because the ideological extremism yeah
that's what which is my point about
what's happening here in the us they
spent so much time worrying about
afghanistan and iraq and iran in between
that they ignored the fact that the u.s
itself is being overrun by a psychotic
cult of people and i'll tell you i love
i love the idea of the cult you know why
because i saw this post about horse
dewormer on reddit okay
listen and the people in the commented
like it's a death cult and i'm like bro
if you actually did two seconds of
google searching you would realize that
certain medications which uh you know
are widely available at walgreens but
for some reason the media keeps saying
horse dewormer over and over because you
are in the matrix
and so here we maybe that's what they're
thinking they're like i don't know let's
have a dumb population that'll allow us
to flourish no it won't a bunch of
people who have no idea what's going on
who can't make any decisions and perhaps
you think that'll empower you but it
guts the country from the inside it's a
brain drain happening in our own country
we've done it on purpose i mean we did
it on purpose because we had these
ideals of what we should be doing
instead of the thing we were doing so
we've gutted our educational system
we've completely devalued the college
degree we've devalued graduate degrees
we've devalued diplomas we don't learn
anything in schools at this point we
don't teach anything you know
i imagine unironically thinking college
is a good idea
right yeah or unironically saying
college is a good idea what i mean i'm
sure that i have a similar experience to
you guys when i was a kid my parents
were like you know you're definitely
going to college
and i'm looking at my son and i'm like
if you want maybe you could go to state
oh i'm i'm totally different from you
i'd be like no yeah make sure you under
understands that compound interest
i'm telling him you know like the money
i have saved for you could also just buy
some property if you want you know you
could travel start a business at 14. you
could do whatever you want with this you
could read you could read on your own on
the internet which is now free exactly
and learn how to discern between real
and fake news
and then teach yourself because there
are a lot of prominent young people or
young people today who are older but
rose to prominence when they were young
because they just went online and
there's some famous stories about young
hackers or like you know let's say tech
entrepreneurs and when they were 15
years old on the internet in forums
contributing code the other 30 year olds
taking that code had no idea was a 15
year old talk contributing right and so
there's a real opportunity to get away
from that broken system but i do think
there's a lot at the end of the tunnel
though with the with the coming collapse
remote working means you'll be around
your kids more often right that is a
that is a plus and remote schooling
means the parents are more likely to be
near their kids when their kids are
learning and to see what's actually
being taught right the cto of mine is
pretty important he was 17 when he
started working with minds i mean you
can do it young you do not need school
this is the big thing why we talk about
the cass castle vlog we've been doing
and building culture
and trying to bring more people here
that's so important that's like the most
important thing is storytelling you know
remembering the old stories i think
that's a big part of it too the more we
replace the canon with things that we
think you know are contemporarily
important
the more we undermine what our culture
is founded on there's a really
interesting we have to go back to the
old stories there's a really interesting
kind of similarity between some of
what's happening with the taliban flying
around in blackhawks and what's
happening in the u.s we have ideological
zealots who have taken over the new york
times for instance and so now they're
wearing it like a skin suit and we see
that with so many different franchises
and movies that's recline at the new
york times we've seen that what what did
he do he's just you know he's writing
these columns all the time that are just
supporting the administration without
any real reason or jennifer rubin today
at the washington post
where she was like
the u.s is still the
the only superpower and it's like girl
if you got to say that we're already in
trouble but so so
the new york times this powerful
institution of you know 100 plus years
or whatever now being worn as a skin
suit by these ideologues
american military power and air force
supremacy with the blackhawks now being
worn by an ideological extremist group
that's you have seized control of this
infrastructure how many missiles i'm not
saying it's identical i'm just saying
they're not going to tell you how many
missiles they left they're not going to
tell you how much equipment did they see
did you see this taliban's new arsenal
graphic was anyone able to yeah there
were some graphics but i couldn't 22
thousand
it's from the us government accounting
office oh interesting what country is
due west of afghanistan that would be
iran and do you think that when
everything starts falling apart in
afghanistan and they need electricity
and infrastructure and resources do you
think they might say hey iran look at
the 42 000 suvs we have might you need
some of this yes i think we have some
hellfire missiles sitting right here in
this building we can't do anything with
them i think you know we do need is
electricity well in iran is uh pretty
close a lot closer to nuclear
capability now at this point anyway i'm
i'm willing to bet the moment
they took a couple like i'm willing to
bet a phone call was made the moment
donald trump signed that peace treaty
iran was immediately like give me you
know like what do you got what are we
gonna do but i'll tell you this
there may have been some phone calls
back and forth back then
the moment word got out that bagram was
abandoned that all of this equipment was
abandoned
iran called up and said you know call of
duty buddy hey how you been
most popular who's always been there for
you what do you think would have
happened if the u.s had left on trump's
timetable
uh it's it's not so much about the
timetable it's about the the caliber of
leadership right
i'm wondering like how that would have
been
if it would have been any different
biden has said repeatedly that he
doesn't think it would have been any
different
i think he's wrong too
it would have been it would it would
have been similar a little more
organized perhaps it's not so much about
the timeline it's the bigger question is
what would have happened if biden stuck
to the arrangements and agreement set
force set forth by the trump
administration how about this why did
they abandon bagram overnight yeah
because they easily could have said
we're evacuating out of pocket why
didn't they evac why didn't they do a in
april i'm i've i haven't factored this
but i've seen some reporting in april
the us issued a warning to american
citizens you need to get out right now a
lot of americans stayed chose to stay
and that is true but i don't think it's
as easy to say that americans were like
well they're choosing to stay that's
their problem well it's probably like
there's people there trying to help and
won't leave behind right and so that
means the u.s need to have a hard
extraction like come on get your stuff
we are leaving you can't stay
uh it's tough though americans do have a
right to choose to stay in the combats
on private contractors or whatever but i
believe
if they stuck to the original plan the
and and i'll tell you this it's it's
more to do with the leadership than just
the plan but if the original plan was
stuck to i don't think this would have
happened i think the taliban would have
absolutely tried moving forward and then
there would have been some very serious
drone strikes drones striking moving
militants through the desert heading to
provincial capitals is a lot easier than
doing a drone strike on residential
houses in kabul which just killed a
bunch of kids yeah i i think that
there's also um something to be said for
sticking to the plan that your
predecessor laid out because
america's word is now garbage we made a
deal and then we were just like meh yeah
but the taliban hold on i feel like
that's a that's a problem
regardless of whether or not you know
the taliban would have stuck to their
end the u.s once once the us makes a
deal like we should stick to that it
shouldn't matter who's in power the
taliban broke the deal
right i'm sorry i'm sorry i take that
back biden broke the deal yeah
we should have said we should have like
you know as soon as he got into office
he should have said something like
if this was the view i don't think we
should leave right away but we said we
would so i'm going to honor
the word of the united states yeah i
feel like he didn't do much about it in
the early days of his presidency yeah he
didn't do anything except reverse
trump bans on critical race theory you
know he spent days
reversing executive orders instead of
actually you know and getting masses of
praise for that i could see like months
and months where they did not do
anything about evacuation even though
they knew they had the timetable because
in the back of his mind he was like f
trump um that guy's i'm not paying
attention that guy whatever i'm not
right i'm focusing on this and he had
months to prepare for this well and i
think he also had this completely
backwards idea that the entire rest of
the world thought that trump was as
illegitimate as the current
administration thinks trump was but in
fact that wasn't the case whether our
allies or enemies or whatever liked or
didn't like trump he was the
legitimately elected president and he
was treated that way as well he should
have been and his bilateral agreements
you know were the word of the united
states whether biden liked them or not
so when he came in he kind of acted like
oh the past four years i can just you
know completely sweep them under the rug
and get rid of everything that happened
during that period of time because
everyone knows that that was an
illegitimate presidency and that was
completely bonkers and and a slap in the
face the american public that voted for
the previous administration joe biden
made a promise
he promised that there would not be
americans left behind from the daily
caller biden breaks his promise and
leaves stranded americans behind at the
mercy of the taliban there's some nuance
here that i do want to i do want to get
into what's it like they said it was
like uh in the low hundreds i think
right today i don't know if i believe
that yeah i mean that's that sounds
absurd to me it's got to be in the
thousands and you saw that question the
other day about transparency where the
one kid was like maybe i'm saying kid
i'm sure he's younger than me anyway but
he was like uh you know you didn't give
us accurate information about dog bites
so why
why do we think that you're giving us
accurate information now major
apparently bit secret service guys for
days and instead of answering the
question of how can we
believe you now when you weren't even
transparent about the stupid dog um jen
saki just gave information about the dog
which may or may not be accurate so this
is from august 19th this promise if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out oh
that's right now they're saying well you
know everybody you want it out we got
them huh
and we can't get them anyway why didn't
they rush why did they rush i don't
understand why no no no no no no rush
yeah why did they rush to get it out by
the 31st what what so what the taliban
they didn't rush well why didn't they
get everybody out i thought the taliban
kind of took over the airport well
that's because they started evacuating
they got rid of bagram bagram they
pulled out all sorts of weird defenses
and logistics earlier i think like hold
on
an attack happened and 13 servicemen and
women were killed
because
the u.s
did not pull them off of the gate of a
uh was it abby gate that's right and
they had forewarning they they warned
others to prepare for an eminent attack
and they did not pull our troops off
that gate they wanted to keep it open a
little bit longer for
the british was it those service animals
americans were told not not to come to
stay away
the the men and women in uniform at the
gate were supposed to shut it down
earlier but they decided to leave it
open and that's what happened and so
they are under fire they're they they
fear more attacks are coming so they
said
pull them out i i'm thinking like grand
grand scheme you got all these people
you need to get out why would they just
not say look it's going to take this
it's going to take us until it takes us
to get these people out the taliban were
they going to attack yes
well we're at war then we attack back
we've been at war for 20 years we're
going to stay there and we're going to
get everybody out that's that's why
what's the it's already bad it's war
there's so many people there that need
our help ron paul i think said it best
when you prescribe the wrong medication
you don't simply say well there might be
a withdrawal so we'll keep him on it no
you get off that medication and that
what he's saying is we should not be in
this country but what if the medication
got people addicted and it's going to
kill them if you take them off it but
it's not the right medicine you've got
to figure out a way to get them off
without killing them that's literally
said even if there would be a withdrawal
withdrawal symptoms from it the point is
you can't we can't just stay we we we
can't reinvade the problem
it's a bunch of back seats
monday morning quarterback sure but i
mean still like what were we supposed to
what would we be doing there right now
other than like getting shot at and
drone bombing
roads
listen this is exactly the problem
that's what we did joe biden botches the
withdrawal and now here you are saying
we should have stayed in exactly what we
should have evacuated
that's why tucker carlson said it seems
like biden did this on purpose and he's
not the only one who said just to make
it look i missed that clip was that like
to make it well many people like we
shouldn't have brought we shouldn't have
left at all was it like to by botching
this withdrawal it would force the u.s
to reinvade and now even trump himself
is saying i would send in more troops
yeah didn't we we didn't send in like 6
000 more troops we did
and so the conservative leaving the
concern is the stupidity
or the malice whichever one it is you
want to believe it was because
abandoning a a two runway air force base
yeah and then
shuttling everybody to the civilian
airport in the middle of a densely
populated city is the stupidest thing
i've ever heard asking permission from
the enemy to allow us to retreat like
come on i get it you do that in war
sometimes and now there are americans
still there because
not having nothing to do with the
timeline the timeline is irrelevant by
its promises are meaningless the point
is the administration is so absolutely
vile and pathetic whether it was
intentional or not they screwed up
everything and maybe they want this
justification uh i don't remember who
was on the show last time they said
maybe it was to punish us that you see
what happens when you want to withdraw
this is what happens and you get to
watch yeah well you it's your fault i
don't care screw all of these people who
started all of it and want to do
everything in their power to make sure
this stuff keeps happening if we didn't
go in there in the first place listen
cassandra fairbanks said it best when
she was on the show talking about china
there are many countries on this planet
that are engaging in atrocities and we
don't report it in the news we don't
talk about it we don't go there we don't
invade we don't colonize but for some
reason some of these countries oh
absolutely yeah what like what did the
taliban say they said how come the us is
okay with saudi arabia that's a really
good question yeah so i'm sick of all of
this i'm i'm sick of their excuses for
how how they break things and then say
oh no oh but if only no no not a phone
you guys broke it on purpose i don't
mean the the the withdrawal i mean the
country itself they wanted a nation
build it was an intentional action to go
into the country start nation building
and the whole thing broke because of it
i think obama's interest was in nation
building because he ran on a platform in
his first campaign he said i'm going to
send more people into afghanistan we're
going to keep doing this uh and i
remember talking to friends at the time
being like he's going to keep this war
going you guys marched with me against
this war when george bush invaded
we you know went into the streets and we
were like don't do this and now you're
voting for obama who is definitely
planning to
keep this war going and that's of course
what happened my favorite was uh people
i knew who voted for obama twice
who then were like we have to vote for
biden i'm like dude you were at occupy
wall street protesting biden like biden
and obama you were mad at them now
you're like biden's are only hope wow
they've sure turned you around they
really they really sold us on this guy
they really sold the country on this guy
it was a false bill of goods they did
such a terrible job they it's like and
everyone just kept backing him all of
the news media for the most part was
backing him you know you had like
universities and institutions and all
the organizations were saying we have to
go with biden all because they hated
trump they did this to us because they
hated trump for their own reasons
without being able to look at you know
policies or whatever and say ah this is
okay this is not good i hate his bluster
but this is you know this is what the
situation is it's a
they created this cult of personality
for trump and then became everything
they hated about him it's it's really
the most amazing stop a puppet
presidency like the the you know the
joke is an alarming number of people who
said punch and nazi are now saying
papers please that punch and nazi thing
was so disturbing 2017 is that when it
got popular remember remember punch it
remember uh remember kill turfs please
you remember that one yeah there was a
there was a kill turfs exhibit at the
san francisco public library there was a
uh there was a baseball bat there was
pink and blue baseball bats to go beat
up women who think biological sex is
innate there was a funny thing that
happened on facebook where a bunch of
feminists were saying kill all men
and then facebook started banning them
and they were shocked and outraged
saying but we're just making a political
point and facebook was like you can't
advocate for genocide
and they were like but like no butts you
can't advocate for genesis but you can't
ever
advocate for punching people of a
political persuasion in the face like
that's so crazy that should be twitter
twitter that stuff gets banned
when i was working at mines that stuff
was not allowed that was a call to
violence it wasn't the thing is it's not
an imminent call to violence because
it's not like punch a nazi at 2 pm
tomorrow that then becomes illegal but
when you just say hurt a person you know
and you're kind of vague about it
there's no imminent threat well the
problem is it's not illegal it's not
those at the time it was the word nazi
now it's like far right everybody is far
right next it'll be what might
there's no definition of what these
things mean we try to understand what it
is but i just love when they like
like i love when they smeared ian trying
to make you seem right wing and everyone
watches the show is like it's so
confusing even to me dude
some sort of tidal wave hurricane it's
like you're you're you're you're a
long-haired hippie guy talking about
psilocybin and dmt all this stuff
transcends political parties that's part
of why i'm here and i enjoy this so much
you know we're people first with like
needs and wants and then the politics
we've just made up all that stuff didn't
used to exist as humans we we've created
it but i i love talking to people who
are you know trying to navigate the
space maybe new to it and they're like
you know are you left or right and
they'll say something like oh i don't
know you know i think i'd be on the left
or like probably middle of the road and
then i say something like
uh what what did i say um
i can't remember there's so many wedge
issues in the culture war but something
like do you think there should be no
medical exemptions for vaccine mandates
and they're like oh well no i don't okay
you're an anti-vaxxer and you're far
right right no joke like if you went
outside and you were standing in front
of a hospital and someone said do you
oppose mandatory vaccination with no
medical exemption you said wow that
sounds really bad aha you're far right
the media would call you far right that
you know that's been happening all over
my facebook so i'll post things i think
it was the the last thing i posted on
facebook was probably uh
tyrant de blasio's
vaccine mandate situation thing and i
was like this is tyrannical and
fascistic and i got so ganged up on for
that and people are saying you know you
give up privacy all the time or you know
you've given away this many of your
rights already so what's a few more
that's a good reason to do it you're
losing so just literally
just give it up all together you know
you've already cut off your right arm so
just cut off your left that's that's
it's the word just mm-hmm it's it's just
a mask calm down justice just 15 days
calm down
just until we can make sure we slow we
slow this down not a big deal why are
you
speaking back against authority and this
is from here's the thing about here's
the thing about the people i'm talking
about here okay these are these are
people that i have known they're all art
these are artists these are actors
they're writers they're directors
they're theater people they're painters
and they're telling me
that my concern about having to show my
paperwork just to order a a drink at a
bar
that makes me a bad person that i would
dare question the authority these are
people who
have for their entire lives until now
said things like question authority you
know
um and then obama comes along first of
all that was the first clue that all
these people are willing to turn tail
right obama comes along and everyone
suddenly trusts the federal government
why would you ever trust the federal
government for anything my i also was in
the theater i found a lot of people in
theaters this is a gross exaggeration i
mean it does definitely isn't going to
be for everybody in the theater but i
think a lot of them are followers that
want to be accepted that are kind of
weirdos that
love being part of a group and that need
to feel like they're not weird and so
now we're seeing that sociologically
because a lot of people i know in the
theater we're like huddling with the
mask and like let the government control
everyone that's what's going on they're
hiding from animals yeah
they they they get into jobs like this
because their goal is to be famous yeah
that's what art used to be
not real that's not how real art used to
be like when i got involved in art i i
was an artist and so i had to be
involved in making art and it had
nothing to do with being famous or
anything like that you know it's it's
nice to have accolades it's nice to have
people recognize
your work and say that they enjoy it but
making art has nothing to do with being
accepted by masses of people or being
propelled into some sort of stardom
that's the complete bastardization of it
you make art because you need to tell
stories because you need to communicate
uh
part of the the river of human
consciousness you need to explore that
you need to
communicate that to people that's what
art is i mean you know
does is art an object or is art the
experience
of
participating in art which one is it is
it both these are the questions that
artists used to ask these are the
questions that we used to
talk about late at night and try and
figure out what kind of work we wanted
to make and now you see what's going on
in the art world and it's all about
propelling your own personal self
forward and hoping you get some sort of
you know i don't know oscar or whatever
the things are it doesn't make any sense
and it's not art it's just another
industry
i noticed uh something really
interesting a great change happened that
makes me kind of happy
several years ago back when i was
working for like vice infusion i would
get emails all the time from people who
are like i want to do what you do you're
so lucky i want to travel the world
report make documentaries it sounds so
amazing and i'd be like well go and do
it go do the thing but they would always
be like oh it's too hard i don't have
enough money it's it's impossible if
only i had your job and i said i just
bought a bus ticket for 20 bucks and
went to new york with a cell phone
granted i had a cell phone but you can
do it right well there were a few people
that i said okay how about this
how about you come
i'll introduce you to a bunch of people
we'll get you a bunch of advice we'll
send you off in the right direction and
they're like wow really like yeah come
hang out by all means we want to support
people who want to do this stuff and you
know what it would happen every single
time
within a week they'd be like i don't
want to do this
oh no hold on what do you mean you don't
want to do this oh they saw how the
sausage got made yeah you mean you have
to actually get on a plane for 12 hours
it's uncomfortable your back hurts then
you land you're groggy-eyed you go
through security they they question you
what you're doing they could turn you
around you got to go to the press
building then you're in a country where
they have no muzzle control and the
egyptians were pointing guns through
people's heads and they're like that
doesn't sound fun that's scary and i'm
like so what did you want to do exactly
well i wanted to be on tv
that's the same thing that used to
happen with art so i was making theater
you know for no money i was like you
know paying stuff out with my own day
job or whatever which was fine i
honored and privileged to do it uh but
people seem to think that the thing
you're doing is something else right so
it's like you show up you work
12 15 hours a day to do the thing to
make the artwork to make that one
crystallized perfect moment that you can
share with the audience and then
everybody loves it and then everyone
wants to yeah because that's what
happens and people are like i want to do
that i want to make that kind of artwork
but they don't actually want to make it
they just want to be part of that final
experience
and it's not the same thing like it's
when you're really when you're doing
successful work you don't realize that
you're successful you're just doing the
thing that you do every day well here's
what the change was so i saw i saw those
people who were just like oh i want to
be on tv i want to be famous and then
something
started to change around the trump era
when trump came out and i saw the media
lying and i'd be like they're lying
about that and they're lying about that
and i don't like hillary or trump or
whatever all of a sudden a lot of these
emails started to stop and today
as much as we get tons of job offers
there's something very different in in
the requests in the i want to do what
you do it's very very different it's the
emails i get now are like i'd love to
help in any way i'm good at doing these
things is that something that you need
it used to be i want to do what you do
and you know you know you know what i
realized
the people who would say things like i
want to do what you do what they were
really saying was
i want to be socially accepted and
famous and now that you are effectively
an apostate of the liberal order by
coming out and being like orange man not
that bad just saying something like that
they're like oh well that won't make me
famous i don't want to do that and i'm
like it's such a relief now because now
i don't get the emails from people who
are like all i care about is notoriety
now that people are like i just care
about doing something good right way
better which is much more important
than notoriety and it also
gives you a life instead of just a
couple of moments the the left has
become overwhelmingly narcissistic
paranoid
delusional and
not every single leftist there are some
dirtbag leftists who are anti-woke and
just believe in like leftist economic
policy and that's fine
but the overarching popular leftists on
youtube are like the most duplicitous es
pro-establishment shills plus then you
have the uniparty which is you know the
neocons and the lincoln project along
with the democrats it's all the same
thing it is a high it is a hive of scum
and villainy and narcissists that's
because they became the thing they hated
they said trump is all of these things
or they were just projecting the whole
time right and we have to beat him no
matter what no matter if we break all
our own rules so they became the
horrible thing that they thought he was
i don't think they have rules
when like listen no no they don't have
rules because there's not a value system
there's no
undercurrent of ethos right it's just
shifting sands when i see someone who
can say something
within the same like hour like there's a
really funny tweet where they're like f
the police f the police
ashley babbitt's shooter was justified
this officer that's a shocking thing to
watch that right so i was what i was
looking today cnn reported about how
pelosi's
special committee on january 6th right
because that's what we're doing now she
reported about how they are now trying
to get telecommunications companies to
fork over
uh phone records for like hundreds of
people including a bunch of um members
of congress members of congress yeah
like mostly gop
legislators like matt goetz and uh
lauren bobert and jim jordan and jim
banks the people that she cut from the
committee in the first place after
mccarthy appointed them
and cnn reported uh the
the committee's investigation into the
deadly riot of january 6th
they keep saying this deadly riot thing
over and over and they refuse to ever
just print where a police officer shot
an unarmed woman to death with no
warning or provocation this is this this
is one of the darkest stories like i
gotta tell you becoming honest from cnn
january 6 committee to ask
telecommunications companies to preserve
phone records of members of congress who
participated in stop the steel rally
they're doing increments yes they
they're preserving the records because
they don't want to come out right they
did a black lives matter did you see
that a blacklist they did a they did a
roundup they demanded all of the
correspondence between oh that's not a
blacklist that's a number of
conservative it was like conservative
journalists and influencers
and a bunch of people in the trump
administration and associates there
right yeah this is the next level so
they're doing it one step at a time
first it's you know we want this
information from the government on these
individuals the trump administration and
all the activists who helped them in
their communications yeah that they
pulled from they're trying to pull down
the archives they want phone records
preserved which means give it a week and
they'll say okay now we want those phone
records that's correct
so this is
and they're threatening talk about the
collapse of afghanistan but this is the
uh uh this is the collapse of the u.s no
no horrifying to watch this unfold and
what we're seeing is that they don't
actually have any evidence of the thing
that they believe happened right there's
no one charged with insurrection that's
exactly right there's very few people
charged with assault there were like
very few people charged with uh previous
conspiracy right and the previous
conspiracy people were like
known members of uh you know radical
organizations
i mean it's like they said
the fbi report said there's no there was
no coordination a central planning scant
evidence yeah
evidence yeah they said there was some
evidence to indicate people planned on
breaking into the building but no actual
plan for what that would entail that's
right so
people smack talking on the internet i
guess that's basically it and mostly
they were doing it on facebook and
friday they pulled parlor down to punish
parlor for facebook's sins and from this
we are now getting the democratic party
going after
their rivals their political opponents
and everything they accuse trump of
doing they are doing right now to the
19th degree that's correct so this is
the end
i can't i can't see how
uh a country can lose in afghanistan
considering the past examples of the
collapses of countries after falling out
failing in afghanistan okay maybe that's
unfair but man was that bad it could
shatter this the empire yeah for sure
like the soviet union cracked but russia
remains so like
even a search warrant you need to have
probable cause and say what you're
looking for in this committee they're
not even saying what they're looking for
because they don't actually have any
idea how they're going to prove that
january 6 was a white supremacist
conspiracy to overthrow the government
they don't care about that they want
phone records because those phone
records will then leak
yes they want all of it because they
don't know what they're looking for i
mean we're at the age of just don't use
a phone don't use don't use unencrypted
communication right
yeah that that funny story we always uh
peop people know it better than i do but
that story about the war game they did
where like the older guy went up against
the younger guys and the older guy won
because he sent communications by a
motorcycle with a written note and they
were trying to do digital and they
couldn't track it or something like that
it's a funny story
yeah but um
i'm you can't not use a phone you know
what i mean you can but you can use
things like signals telegram signal yeah
telegram and signal you can you can set
up custom operating systems you can
learn how to flash you know different
operating system on your phone it's not
the easiest thing in the world but it's
not particularly difficult but i think
the bigger issue here is it's not about
it's not about looking for evidence what
they're doing is they're saying for one
if you oppose us we'll dig through all
your records we know those records will
leak to the press whether it's social
media or telecommunications and more
importantly they're looking for strategy
they wanted information on all of these
people from april 2020 to january 2020
right once they have the uh once they
have that information could people just
put in foia requests for it
i don't well so the issue with the first
request on social media was that they
want government communications things
that already exist right so
entirely possible now that they've made
national archive stuff now that they've
made the announcement that these things
potentially exist i'm sure buzzfeed
already went to town subpoenaing every
single one of these individuals it's
it's actually there's a funny thing that
i did advice once we we wanted to do we
never actually did we were planning it
was to do a four request on ourselves
and see what comes up and then whoever
gets the biggest stack is the winner
you know actually
north korea venezuela you'd wonder who
has the bigger you know fbi file or
whatever
so uh but you can easily do this you can
now foil your request saying like oh the
democrats
uh requested this i would like public
information you know these documents to
be released to the public on all of
these individuals and what they were
saying and it's going to leak regardless
of foreign well the national archives i
don't think have turned over the
information yet i think they have to
like september 9th it'll happen you
think so it's the second request congr
the uh committee asked for it i think
some of it back in march or something
yes so some of it's a lot of the request
is new some of it didn't get turned over
but i think it will interesting
resistance before no i think they just
didn't do it
i don't know i mean the national
archives they're probably sitting there
like really we got to do something why
it's a lot of work the cia
the cia can look at anybody's info at
any time without a request that they can
do like a kangaroo court and get a foia
or whatever that fisa yeah fisa um but
congress has to get
uh permission is this is what we're
learning right um because they have
subpoena power yeah i mean this
committee has that power
they could just subpoena but i think
they're slow rolling it that's why
they're saying preserve records yeah
that's why they're not saying we demand
all records immediately they're slow
rolling it so that people don't get
shocked they want the frogs to boil not
jump out of the pot right
these are these are these are
truly dark i know it's annoying i
thought that the government was going to
help me also the uh
also the uh
the difference
i was like
in the u.s oh really i thought you meant
like recently i was like oh no way dude
for like last 30 years i was like sweet
right i was like after everything you've
said like government's awesome aren't we
still waiting for the durham report to
come out also because the
um
but i think it was
you you due
like for a second they're like is he
being serious
yeah that's not going to happen after i
was in a little car wreck today you know
oh man it's a little i don't think
there's going to be a durham report
right you saw a uh four-car pileup you
were talking about oh yeah yeah it was
it was behind me that's crazy you barely
avoided it i was like fast and furious
and you like drifted and the car flew
over you you're like
you rose up out of the car and your
screen lays down no there was this crazy
truck driver he didn't break in time he
smashed into a whole bunch of people and
the car behind me like smashed into
smashed into us and then i hit the gas
and we like got out of there did you
fear for your life at any time in that
kind of yeah
i'm a new driver i'm a neutral i've only
been driving for like less than a year
now like we talk politics yeah yeah but
like when your life is on the line look
at these people in louisiana right now
with this hurricane we didn't even talk
about it how many people are stranded
right now haven't roofs coming off of
hospitals dude i remember that that one
in was 2003 the hurricane that george
bush katrina katrina and they they they
mishandled that terrible
people died from in that people were on
their own yeah now we're truly entering
the panopticon drone footage flying
overhead filming people looting
buildings oh wow in louisiana so
speaking of surveillance
and then shutting down the
the the air space over that wreckage
earlier is probably because they don't
want the panopticon right yeah yeah i
think we're headed towards a future
where there's going to be drones over
your backyard you're going to be in your
bathroom and the government drone is
going to like fly to the window and
you're going to be like naked it's going
to be like do not be alarmed
we are simply doing an id check and
you're going to be like okay it's not
going to be the government drone it's
going to be amazon
well maybe not tesla apple
tesla's going to have some kind of weird
musk type implosion situation but it's
definitely going to be amazon saying
stay in your homes we will bring you the
things that you require
that was a uh what what what show was i
watching i think those electric dreams
that the one i was talking about a
little bit where it's like the uh the
the ai system wipes out humanity by just
mass producing products of want and so
then eventually humans are just
strangled out from the dying environment
and they're like the machines just drop
boxes of random garbage but i i think
i think what what we'll likely see is
with moves like this over the uh you
know january 6 they're going after
politicians they're going after
prominent activists this really does
paint a picture of that future where
amazon is like there's a uniparty like
we had a uniparty for some time but
they'll lucratively merge with the likes
of amazon or whatever well that's
already happening i mean when you see
you know the administration was asked if
they were going to do vaccine passports
and they said no there will be no
vaccine federal vaccine credential right
but then they supported states doing it
they supported cities doing it and they
have been encouraging businesses to do
it themselves so you see that they're
they're already teaming up they're
already creating this corporate federal
infrastructure that is horrible
horrifyingly difficult to
get out of like the ccp yeah
you know i think that's real i mean this
is something i think is definitely
happening and it's happening with all of
our acquiescence we like having
little pieces of garbage delivered to
our homes i just watched this really
amazing classical movie it's called um
it's called uh
fast and furious
one of the classics and there's i've
never i've never seen this film it's
good it's you got to see it you know why
because i was watching it and the bad
guy's name is reyes no hold on listen
okay the bad guy's name is reyes okay
and he's a brazilian like crime lord and
he was in the beginning of the movies is
really it's a profound moment i was
thinking about this he was talking to
these two guys and he says you know i
don't want to work with you your your
methods are too violent you know when
you get violent and you back someone
into a corner they have nothing left to
lose and they fight back
i give them something to lose and then i
own them and i was like wow yeah that's
that's that's something big like who i i
didn't think i was gonna get any kind of
philosophy from fast fast and furious
but to say like give the people
something to lose and then threaten to
take it away
that's why the americans don't wanna
fight that's why people don't
i mean i'm not speaking for everyone
here
yeah there's too much to lose
like a nuclear war would i mean yeah the
people and somalia would lose stuff but
we would no no no look look at the
people who trespass and are getting six
months in prison and most of them were
like bankrupt already a lot of these
people had nothing you know i think
ashley babbitt for example
was like facing bankruptcy so these are
people like reyes said and fast and
furious who had nothing left to lose
and so now they're saying that what
they're doing to these people is a
reminder you still have something left
to lose we will lock you up and torture
you in solitary confinement for eight
months
and then you'll realize what you've got
to lose and people are going to see that
that's the message they're sending give
the people something to lose and you
will own them it's messed up did you see
what remember you know adam kokesh did
you see what they did to him back a
couple few years ago he went to dc and
protested with a shotgun an open carry
and they were like well that gives us
you know um what do they call it when
they have probable cause yeah probable
cause to search your apartment so they
went to his house and they found
mushrooms in his apartment threw him in
prison for mushrooms just devastated him
and he came out a completely different
person like he does not talk crap about
the government anymore
yeah terrifying because he was a
hardcore actress
ex-military
really they just look for it they bring
the hammer when they come he doesn't do
any anti-government i shouldn't say any
but he's not the outspoken vocalist that
he was in the early days like screaming
profanity-laced tirades about the
military industrial complex because of
mushrooms
we're going to have a medical did you
see how the government wants to
expand the federal
reach into uh medical research no that's
awesome for
what for mushrooms uh for all of it
really yeah well there you go
this is part of uh this is part of uh
biden's infrastructure plan is it's like
billions of dollars to create
uh more federal medical infrastructure
so i don't like it either and the idea
is that when we need vaccines we would
just have the government do it we
wouldn't have to
you know engage american industry in
doing these things in a competitive way
i was talking to a friend
and uh they were saying something to me
like this is kind of a lefty person
they're like i'm really scared about
what's happening with these these
coveted numbers skyrocketing and i was
like
i get it but i'm like at what point do
you just stop believing everything
because of how much they've been wrong
you know what i mean i'm not not to say
don't believe the numbers or anything
i'm just like at a certain point don't
you throw up your arms in futility like
i've done everything they've said
nothing's changed we we got vaccinated
we wore two masks it's all the same and
and they just keep blaming other people
and the response was like but the
government's really really scared and
that freaks me out and so it's like
i don't know i guess there are some
people there's there's two ways you can
go when you come to the futility of like
i just don't know anymore i'm i'm broken
mentally on this one i've seen too much
reverse like reversions and back and
forth i'm just like you go do your thing
i don't even know but then other people
say i give up just tell me what to do i
don't want to think anymore i think that
is the point i think it's an intentional
confusion so once you you know once we
give up logic we have nothing and the
regulations and the rules that are
coming down to us don't make any
cohesive sense they're not based on
anything right and so if you look to for
example absurdist literature from
eastern europe during the cold war if
you look at like kafka or if you look at
vaclav havel right who was brilliant
playwright who ended up president of the
czech republic randomly um after the
velvet revolution but you can see in
this literature
uh
where these writers have discovered um
or they rather elucidate the way that
communism worked in those nations where
it's like they tell you one thing and
then they do something else like if you
look at uh
the trial right did you read kafka's
trial so
i read this in high school um
and uh i had to convince them to let me
read it but whatever so this guy uh kaye
ends up on trial and he can never get
any real information as to what he's on
trial for what it's about
who his solicitor is uh what the
punishments are going to be it's all
just very confusing and it's very much
like in metamorphosis where he becomes
the bug right so the guy became this is
probably easier to explain but so he
becomes he wakes up one morning he's a
cockroach he's horrified that he's a
cockroach he doesn't know what to do
about it he goes all through how am i
going to explain this what am i going to
do i don't know as soon as he accepts
the fact that he's a cockroach and
nothing makes any sense and there's no
way out of it that's the end that's sort
of that's kind of the whole thing he's
like i'm gonna go eat some garbage no he
just kind of dies he like dies under his
bed i think well that's brutal well yeah
but that's
that's what this is if they confuse you
enough if they make you so confused that
you stop questioning it because to
question it itself is going to make you
crazy
that's sort of the end goal because then
you don't question then you just do what
you're told you just show up where
you're supposed to show up you hand over
what they tell you to hand over and in
return you get to what like have a drink
on smith street and watch the simpsons
yeah yeah watch the simpson and like
jerk off right you get to do that too i
studied about the they even gave
everyone their only fans back
they're like we can't take that away
it's distracting people it's too much i
took this i tweeted this thing out it's
on my twitter feed somewhere um about
the gamification of trust sociological
trust and what's happening according to
this game theory study is that not that
we've been overloaded with communication
and that there's too much of it all this
new information you know the the red
pilling and the the war on terror and
the the all that but it's that the
amount of misinformation is causing
people to distrust each other
and then the cheaters the ones that are
willing to to game that and work with
the distrust are are proliferating as a
result and if there's too much
misinformation cheaters will overwhelm
the system and then you'll have a system
of cheaters
if there's not too much just uh distrust
or misinformation then the the copy the
people that are willing to kind of play
the game are gonna over override the
cheaters there are some prominent
leftist personalities who have always
claimed to be anti-fascist who are all
of a sudden now making youtube videos
being like why would anyone oppose
government mandates on forced medical
procedures and i'm like it's so weird
you know for me i've always been so in
favor of that freedoms i've always been
opposed to the coalescing of corporate
power that i find myself aligned with
whoever at the time seems to oppose the
coalescing of massive corporate and
government power so it used to be the
left and all of a sudden they're all pro
corporate power and now it's the right
and i say it all the time in a few years
you know there will be a shift backwards
and the uh you know it's people like
like jack murphy a really great example
of somebody who was a democrat now he's
like democrat to deplorable and i don't
think it's that he's a republican by
party he's a republican by you know
who's willing to support more of his
ideals and i feel that way so i have a
feeling that a lot of people like us who
are like maybe in the middle right now
leaning to one side or the other will
shift back and forth depending on which
tribe wants to actually adopt freedom
and which who's actually willing to back
our natural rights uh to what you were
saying in um you know about this
misinformation thing
people aren't able to think critically
so they're not able to differentiate
between what's you know
supposedly misinformation and what's
actually true or anything like that and
in part that's because we've completely
destroyed our educational system so
we've destroyed the canon we've
destroyed the literary canon we've taken
away
shakespeare and homer and you know all
of this other stuff that used to tell us
kind of a
timeline of this is a timeline of human
thought about ideas this is how you can
you know track truth this is how you can
understand things
we've taken that all away we've replaced
it with stuff that we think is
appropriate to think about now
and we've been left with a public that
doesn't know how to think clearly
because we haven't given them any
examples as to how to do so i'd like to
read a text message i received allegedly
from the aclu right i have a series of
text messages from a number from
well i'm not going to say the number but
it's an aclu number supposedly they say
as schools start nationwide kimberly
crenshaw talks teaching the truth about
race in america check out our podcast
back to school merch that back civil
liberties
why did the aclu texted me saying that
kimberly crenshaw is going to you know
have a podcast about back to school
stuff she is she like listen she created
intersectionalism kimberly crenshaw is
as close as you can get to being a nazi
as you can in the modern era in my
opinion when i see the stupid people
walking around with the symbols of the
nazi party or whatever or like the
bikers who do it because they're trying
to be you know punk or edgy or
anti-establishment that's very different
from someone who is overtly identitarian
wanting government based on race and is
a proponent of
fascistic uh ideologies whether they
assert them
like verbatim or not but the people who
are like i believe the government should
have absolutely authority do these
things and also i think the law should
be based on race okay yeah that's as
close as you can get to what the nazis
were doing so when i see some of these
prominent you know leftist youtubers
over a million subs and they're like you
know these anti-vaxxers are saying that
the vaccine mandates are bad and the
government shouldn't be doing this but
people just do it the government tells
them i'm like
so you support race-based ideology
identitarianism so does the government
you support massive multinational
pharmaceutical countries getting getting
guaranteed no liability contracts and
you support the government forcing
people to undergo medical procedures yo
you're nazis yes you're as close as you
can get to it you're at very you're at
the very least fascist yes i'm gonna i'm
just gonna go straight for violating
godwin's law right away
because because it's it's the look when
someone's like you know you just want
people to live the way you want because
you're a nazi it's like well well hold
on
i personally think people should take
care of their own decisions and take
care of themselves and their friends and
their families so long as they're not
hurting other people it's the
it's the dominant left democrat faction
that are basically saying pro-corporate
power
guaranteed contracts for massive
unaccountable pharmaceutical countries
and the government will mandate the
medical companies
pharmaceutical countries
you said that dude are you are you
prophesying something
i know we have theocracy you see you see
what's happening because they're merging
in my mind like i'm i'm i'm oh
massive multinational corporations
say here is the product and these these
these left establishment people are
going yay save us big pharma and then
the government says and you have to buy
their product and they go yay save us
and i love it jan kueger of the young
turks said do you think if the if the
right wingers came out and said seat
belts were tyranny that they would all
stop wearing them and i'm like yo
libertarians do think
forcing people to wear seat belts is
tyranny and you know what i remember
this back in illinois when they passed
the uh the law saying you have to wear a
seat belt click it or ticket
and what i was told i'm not saying it's
true because i was a kid at the time and
it was just the scuttlebutt i heard from
the adults was yeah the insurance
companies were lobbying for seat belt
laws because it
made sure their profits stayed the same
because you have to have insurance but
it meant their payouts would go down
because people were less likely to get
injured and the politicians saw it as a
safety issue and the insurance company
saw it as a reducing their their uh you
know their expenses issue so yes it very
well very much was in this bloom
burgarian idea of the people are too
stupid to live their own lives so the
nanny status tell them what they have to
do and now we have click it or ticket i
hate the thing too where it's like
people are like why don't you you know
the vaccine is free just get it and it's
like it's not it's so obviously not free
the pfizer one is like 1925 a shot the
other ones are like 10 bucks or
something like that it's like my kid is
going to be paying for all of this stuff
what they were doing free vaccines for a
while but i think that ended didn't it
no i'm pretty sure it's still free
you could get it free at the rite aid oh
i thought you were saying it wasn't free
no it is free but it's not free i mean
it's not actually free so the government
is paying for it oh right right right
our taxes are paying so we're paying for
it and the administration is like
sending out 250 a month to families who
have kids for like every kid
see this is weird but the thing too is
like this booster shot thing right so
now booster shots every five months yeah
so we're just gonna keep paying for that
forever it's like they finally figured
out a way to turn us all into lifelong
medical patients they've been trying to
do that for a while now and here it is
and so at a certain point your vaccine
passport is useless anyway unless you
re-up your
your dose here we go from insider
business insider fauci says u.s still
planning for covet 19 booster after
eight months biden said shots could be
administered after five i know some
people who already got theirs and it
hasn't been eight months wow there was a
there was a tweet i saw where they were
like uh well now all the data screwed up
because we had like the regimen you know
two shots and then we'll track what
happens and now people are getting more
and look i i say it i say it all the
time
when
there was a there's a report we also
have let me see if i can pull this up
this is from timcast.com switzerland
warns a potential terror attacks on
vaccination sites the swiss federal
intelligence service voiced its concern
with the national newspaper of the
weekend
that is horrifying if people
go to their trusted medical professional
do some research or whatever make a
decision for themselves and that means
they want to go get the vaccine they
should be allowed to do it nobody should
be stopping people from getting
medicated whatever that medication might
be because there are a lot of people who
are like you know that particular
antibiotic is bad for this reason it's
like dude mind your own business and so
when it comes to fouchy and and biden
another discussion around five months
you'll get a booster the problem is
not in my opinion the vaccine the
problem is the authoritarianism
that that is the problem with it yeah i
mean i i was vaccinated like the problem
is telling everybody what to do and
making making listen
i was just talking about okay i mean
we get to have decisions
i was talking to a lefty friend of mine
and i said you are supporting a massive
guaranteed no liability contract for big
pharma it's the opposite of universal
health care and if this goes through you
will never see universal health care the
other no that's interesting the other
thing too is there
have been
you know any time anyone tries to make a
report about some concern with the
vaccine um
that gets squashed by social media
instantly
so there's no way to have a public
conversation
uh because everyone's already everyone's
opinions have already been bought and
sold so you're not allowed to the rules
for instance here putin says no to
mandate uh vaccine mandates is this have
you guys confirmed this at all because
yes
who's reporting on it because i can't
find any large organization reporting on
this i've got we love trump.com corona
coronanews123.wordpress like who but
okay
what
talk about authoritarianism or the lack
thereof when the russian premier is
decided president as that's what he's
called they're not going to do mandates
if that's real
i think this all comes down it hinges on
do you then they'd have to give it away
anyway so maybe that's part of what it
means well they don't they don't uh
properly they don't want to pay for all
those vaccines for their entire
population maybe that's a good point
yeah another another reason but it just
this entire thing hinges whether or not
these people are nazis whether blah is
like what's the threat level of cove
this story is actually pretty old uh
i've got something from this is funny it
didn't come up on google but it came up
on duckduckgo
putin says russia won't make covet
vaccines compulsory but skepticism
remains a problem it's from may 27th
interesting google searched i couldn't
find anything yes from a date and then i
went on duckduckgo and it popped right
up okay maybe it's maybe it's just a
resurged uh article i know he got the
vaccine or maybe he said something
recently yeah isn't it crazy i saw a
comment where somebody i think was on
reddit where they were talking about
how uh you know emigrating to the united
states and wondering if now they
actually want to go back you know to to
russia
oh that's interesting yeah because of
what's happening in the united states is
is
it's absolutely insane dude i mean it
looks absolutely insane i hear the i
hear these stories from friends where
they're like watch this they're like oh
my friend texted me you know about like
being friends with you or
you know or like someone will say
something like i got i got a text from a
friend where they were like i can't
believe you would be friends with this
person or that person i can't believe
you would watch this show or that show
you know or you watch alex jones like
how could you watch or listen to dave
rubin he's far right you know
and i'm like you know what this reminds
me of reminds me of being a kid and
having people being like i can't believe
you turned away from the church i can't
believe it what's what's happened to you
and it's like
this this this level of dogmatic faith
and this emotional manipulation of
messaging someone and saying these
things i'm like yo these people are in a
cult well it's apostasy right because
you've committed apostasy that's what it
is here's the important thing
when someone would join a cult back in
the day you could take them away from
the cult and deprogram them but you had
to get them away from the cult you can't
do it anymore
yeah it's everywhere it's linked into
their minds well and now they're fed
back that same algorithm
so there's it's very hard to break away
from that you have to go to duckduckgo
yeah apparently even then when i
searched putin vaccine on duckduckgo i
got putin gets coronavirus vaccine from
march well you have to search for the
title like putin says no vaccine yeah no
i mean yeah you're right i'm not an
expert with searches um
search for the words search for that i
will find that give me the words tim i
just searched for uh uh
go putin vaccine mandate
and then a bunch of stories popped up
putin says no compulsory vaccines yeah
rock i mean to be fair biden said no
compulsory vaccines from r2 well but he
lied well i got cnbc right here cool
well he
the government isn't uh like the federal
government isn't doing it bill de
blasio's doing it at the city level yeah
and all these other cities san jose is
doing it yeah and new orleans and san
francisco and they're all doing this
with the full backing of the federal
government biden goes out there and says
that he wants everybody to do this he
encourages
big companies to i think it was just
recently like the other day when uh when
the fda approved the vaccine was it like
a week ago
and he encouraged big companies to
require all their employees to get
vaccinated this is another really weird
thing that i've talked about before but
people keep emailing me claiming that
the vaccine the pfizer vaccine isn't fda
approved and they're using like it's the
weirdest thing a twisted semantic
argument that is not oh is this that's
the like other drug that has a different
name community
which is literally the exact same
vaccine as per the fda letter and so
when bannon was here he mentioned this
and i was like uh i don't think that's
true and i googled it i'm like it says
right here it is the vaccine that is
approved and then i got a bunch of
emails like bannon is right tim take a
look at this and there are a bunch of
articles like you know patriot national
you know info or whatever and it says
something like take a look at this
letter and so i read the fda letter and
it literally says the formulation is
identical and interchangeable but one is
the marketing brand either can be used
because they're the same thing yeah what
he was saying i thought was that pfizer
has a bunch of different vaccines that
it's working on and only one of them has
been fda approved that's the community
one so when people say the pfizer
vaccine is fda approved they're they're
not being accurate because there's it's
one of the pfizer vaccines there's one
covet 19 pfizer vaccine it is being
marketed as community they are the same
exact vaccine under just different names
the fda letter says it is
commonly known as the pfizer bioentec
vaccine which will now be marketed as
community they are interchangeable and
the and an identical formulation
and so for some reason people are
claiming
you know they're actually two different
ones i'm like what do you what yeah is
fizer working on other coveted vaccines
i don't know but i thought that's what
steve was saying no so people keep
emailing me this thinking that there's
some like underhanded scheme to like
trick people into thinking that
community is available but it's not
really that way they're not liable and
it's like no no just like did you read
it and so i just took a quote from the
letter and it says like these are
identical interchangeable and the same
exact formulation and i email it back
i'm like i don't know why you thought
that was true did you read the letter
right but people i think i think it's
because
when a lot of people said oh you know
i'm not going to get it until it's fda
approved right and that was their like
rationale and then once it got approved
they needed to maintain a rationale well
then that was biden's whole speech last
week was like all you people who were
waiting for now it is i think just a
certain everyone just
get it if you if you really are like you
know
just just say it just publicly state how
you feel about it and don't rely on
semantic arguments right and maybe if
you don't want to get the vaccine or any
medical treatment then that's kind of up
to you it's up to you and i am not going
to give people medical advice when it
comes to like mandating it and whether
those people are nazis that want the
government to mandate this is like how
dangerous is covent that's what we have
to ask because when when people got
polio and were getting paralyzed they
didn't say it was authoritarian nazism
to mandate a vaccine they just did it
well maybe they did actually i wasn't
around my dad got it you know he took it
on the arm there were a lot of people
who didn't want to get it and also the
federal government at the time put out a
few different statements saying
you know
as people get this vaccine people are
going to die
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
from the vaccine people die anyway and
sometimes these things are going to be
um
you know coincidental this the cdc says
it very very bluntly they said it to me
in a statement as i interviewed people i
i actually interviewed one of the
highest guys at the cdc and like his
full military uniform a few years ago
and they said
we know there are side effects and
adverse effects we know that some people
face problems but it percentage-wise it
is substantially better that people get
vaccinated than not even with a side
effects basically they're saying the
needs of the money outweigh the needs of
the few or the risk from the vaccine is
substantially lower than the risk from
not getting it for society as a whole so
my thing is like i'm very much for the
individual i think you have to find
someone you trust
when it comes to medicine a medical
professional and come to a personal
decision that that i'm not going to make
for you
that's even
what you were saying talking to that cdc
official a few years ago
that's even different than the messaging
we're getting now right no i don't think
so i think it's on the website the cdc
literally
okay yeah but from the mainstream media
from social media from like the way that
that message is interpreted
um that sounds very reasonable right the
way that that message is interpreted is
almost as though to say the american
public is too stupid to figure out
what to do literally said that yeah and
so you know
the way it's interpreted is that people
are not trusted to make their own
decisions that's the problem right if
that was what we hear all the time and
people were like oh that's interesting
i'm going to make my own decision i'm
going to think about it but people are
told not to think about it to just do
what they're told and that's that's the
issue this is the problem this is why i
think we're always all collapsing first
we got the failure of afghanistan the
absolute chaos of the baby
administration donald trump was
anti-elected so people voted not for
biden they voted against
trump but it's like the most extreme
degree i've ever seen in my life
you have economic crisis labor shortages
and you have no
national unity and i don't mean just
like obviously there's a culture war i
mean quite literally a crisis happens
there's 15 days to slow the spread and
then instantly
every single grifter of grifters comes
out to make money the pharmaceutical
companies want no bid guaranteed no
liability contracts the government just
says fine then then all of these local
jurisdictions are like i don't care i
don't want to be held responsible so
whatever that guy says you do
all that's happening is people are
saying i want nothing to do with you
i want stuff for me like i said what
we're seeing is the elites
knowing that we hit an iceberg and
they're stealing all the silverware and
running to the safe to the safety boats
before anyone realizes what's happening
this was interesting too the other day
uh so we have a mayoral election going
on in new york city uh de blasio is
going to be out which is great eric
adams is the he won the democratic
primary in june he was the brooklyn
borough president um he's relatively
popular he was not the far left
candidate so people were just pleased
that he won that primary but anyway he's
running against uh curtis sliwa
who
was recently doing a um
like you know doing a campaign event
that was interrupted by a homeless guy
who was started like yelling about stuff
and
seliwa went over to him he wasn't miked
you know he just went over and started
talking to the guy and being like oh you
know talking to him like a human being
which obviously he is uh what's your
situation you know have you been are you
supposed to be taking medication have
you been hospitalized and the guy breaks
down
and says you know i don't want to be a
burden to anybody i don't you know i
don't want to to do this to everybody
and sleep was like no you're you're not
like you're our responsibility
and then he asks him do you want to
stand here with us do you want to stand
here with us yeah now the current
administration de blasio de blasio's
wife shirlene mcrae tweets out like if
you see homeless people call the
homelessness outreach line you had uh
bloomberg saying you know previously
saying uh
if you see homeless people in need of
help you know
don't help them yourself
call somebody and call the homelessness
outreach to go help them and i think
this is part of it too we don't take any
responsibility for our neighbors we
don't take any care for the people
around us we assume that there's always
somebody else who's supposed to do that
thing and that maybe we should let them
know hey
there's someone bleeding to death over
here i'm gonna be late for coffee you
know so i can't do it you deal with it
and we see that all over the place in
our culture where we are supposed to put
our trust in
the government we saw this with obama
and i think in a lot of ways this goes
back to obama like obama had this whole
um
like a video for obamacare right that
was this woman
and i think her name was julie in the
advertising and she was uh she was just
all by herself and at every turn the
government was there to help her right
down to at a certain point she had a
child and the government was there to
help her
she had a child there was still nobody
else in the picture at that point there
was still just her in the child there
was no one else that she could there was
no father right is my point bad
marketing it was weird marketing at the
time and i remember looking at it being
like i don't want to have a baby with
the government you know
i'm not up for that that's weird and
creepy and that's where we've landed i
was recently
again like facebook with people that
i've known for a long time or whatever
and there was a woman who was saying
that uh someone in california had um
come up with a lot of money for
homelessness housing and she found this
infuriating because this was a private
guy and she was like you know why
why do we need this private guy to come
up with homelessness housing uh it's not
his responsibility the government should
be doing this and i was like no this guy
should be doing it if he thinks that
this is his responsibility to take care
of people then he should be doing it
obviously we can't just have a
government and say
everybody just rely on the government
and the government will come and
interfere in every aspect of our lives
we should want to take responsibility
for each other we should want to care
about our neighbors and be cared about
why do we not want that
there was an old woman who died next
door to me i had only met her two times
and i felt so uh
stupid that i had you know barely ever
interacted with her and then her son
shows up to clear out her apartment and
he's like
do you want you knew my mother and i was
like dude i met your mother twice like
please don't
give me her valuable things i don't you
know
yeah i'll give you i have a garbage who
lives next door to her like never you
know shout out to luke's luke's video we
mentioned before it's called i think
it's called like just keep going you've
got nothing to lose lukerkowski from we
are change and it's this old video you
made back like 10 years ago where he's
like you know i take the train every day
in new york and there's millions of
people but i noticed they never talked
to each other so one day i decided to
start talking to these people and then
he films and asked them questions that
you know get kind of weird like do you
trust the government but i think it's
funny and it makes a good you know
emotional point anyway
that like people in new york city they
live around each other they're not
neighbors neighbor is the wrong word
that is exactly the wrong word remember
exactly mr rogers
would say
hello neighbor
that meant something yeah now it's like
you're not my neighbor like you live
next to me and you yell too much yeah
i've actually started trying to like
talk to the people in my building now
ever since this woman died i was like
well that sucks uh and so i've tried to
talk to people and they just kind of
look at me but i'm good i think i'm
gonna keep it up but there's this um
there was a sign on the mta speaking of
not talking to each other on the mta
with covid right so there were
three options and the mta let you know
which one was the appropriate option the
first option was to stick figures having
a conversation with no masks looking
animated having a conversation and it
said not this
the next one was people wearing masks
having a conversation and it said not
this and then the final one was two
people looking down separately at books
not looking at each other having no
communication at all and the mta was
like this
this is what we want you to do
don't talk to anybody don't look at
anybody don't be near anybody don't
exist with other people just live in
your own literal bubble behind your face
covering
and go about your business
that's the brave new world we live in
yeah that's what happens when you let
the
corporations take over men whether it's
the city the state the the corporate
corporation the centralized authority
makes these stupid machine-like rules
and restrictions on humans when we're
not machines
i watch this movie it's called i think
it's called 2149 where it's like people
live in concrete pods their whole lives
and they just all they do is play video
games
and they interact without just by typing
and that's like the world that's the em
forester story also the machine stops
did you ever read that no no what's that
it's a free download in fact you can get
it because it's uh out of what do you
call it copyright the machine stops ian
forrester wrote this book nineteen i
don't know 1914
1918 i don't know when it was something
like that
and uh
all of these people live underground in
their own little studio apartments and
whenever they need anything they ask the
machine for it and the machine will
provide it whether it's food or anything
else whenever they want to talk to each
other they all deliver lectures on
basically telescreens
and it's basically the internet and
that's how they talk to each other and
they respond 1909 1909 there you go yeah
interesting yeah this is a fascinating
story and so basically he predicted
people sit in their mom's basements yes
yes playing warcraft yeah and he
predicted online dating as well
because the main character this woman i
think her name is uh vashti or something
so she lives in her little underground
cubby she delivers lectures through
telescreen and most of her lectures most
of the things she delivers she talks
about our responses to other people's
lectures and it is at the beginning of
the story she talks about how she was
listening to a symphony and there was a
glitch in it and when she first
recognized that when she first heard the
symphony with the glitch she was very
upset and she was you know wanted to
complain about this glitch and now she
wouldn't recognize the symphony without
it
creepy it's very creepy and also she has
a child but she had a child with a man
who showed up
they
you know
engaged
had a child and he left and she never
saw him again
so it's it's tinder it's serious
everything it's amazon
and then of course the machine breaks
down and so all of the people eventually
they start like pouring out of their
cubbies and the little transport system
doesn't work
um
and her son who had contacted her makes
his way to the surface
to breathe air for the first time and
it's poison and it kills him and he dies
but he
is nice
wow em forrester is amazing that led me
to read everything em forester ever
wrote and that's really the best thing i
should have just stopped there well how
about we go to super chats smash the
like button give it a gentle little tap
do it for ian just love it yeah just do
it for you and everybody you have to
make love and go to timcast.com become a
member there's going to be a member
segment coming up we usually post them
around 11 or so p.m that will be for
members like i said so make sure you
subscribe to the channel and become a
member over there smash the like button
let's read some super chats
deplorable pirate captain gunbeard says
according to a new study kids aged 5 to
11 went from an obesity rate of 36
percent to 47 percent because of the
lockdown in the u.s
that's really bad for people i mean
that's a lot jason d
says tim you got some interference on
your show yes i think it was because the
microphone may have been rubbing against
the power cable which causes
interference so the problem is it
doesn't seem to be consistent it seems
to be intermittent uh intermittent so i
just moved the cables hopefully that
solves the problem but we'll figure it
out
all right let's see
jeffrey pfaff says iran iran still flies
usf5 1965 with heavy sanctions that is
amazing
yikes i guess they know how to keep them
up
all right let's see moonlight film says
why does the biden pull out got to be
worse than tim pool's internet
connection that is that is not fair rude
the interruptions we've had the past the
few times for the past couple of weeks
was on youtube's end not our end our
internet is working we have got this
robust multi
network system with fail safes and the
web was dropping out not because of us
we had a clean connection the whole way
through
all right let's see
hayden says random but i thought of
something
let's see uh did you do hit irs in fed
where it hurts by passing amendment
where employers can't take taxes
medicare anything out of employee checks
forcing people to write a check to it to
the irs every year so it is more clear
that return was their money already you
see that's the issue people get paid and
their taxes are taken out instantly as a
convenience right no it's so that they
don't realize i remember when i first
met like my second job
actually like my fourth or fifth job but
like my first big corporate job and they
were like it's it's you know 10 25 an
hour so i was counting the hours
and then i was like okay so i worked 40
hours i should be getting about this
much money taxes will probably come out
to this so i think i'll get this and i
got like half and then i remember
looking at my check and i'm like hold on
a minute and they looked through it they
did the math that's right and i'm like
yo i'm poor yeah i can't afford to get
five bucks take home like what is this
i saw it happen so well i guess what i
mean to say is
for a lot of middle class people they
don't realize at the end of the year
you're like yo i got a big refund yeah
and they high five and it's like oh so
the money that was taken from you just
found his way back that's great yeah and
then you more people see it the
government earns the interest on your
money and you don't get to earn it
yourself yeah yeah i make a lot of money
with that i bet they're all too i'm sure
they do a lot of delinquencies when
people would just get their full
paycheck in the end of the year had to
pay taxes and they were like i wasn't
planning for this right
then there's this weird thing too so the
administration is giving out like money
for kids right so every child every
family every kid uh 250 a month
um and i'm wondering what's going to
happen when it turns out that they've
been sending 250 checks to a bunch of
people who aren't actually eligible for
that child
that like same kind of deduction or who
owe money and
that's going to be screwed up wow there
are a couple of super chats asking about
this paula ramirez says sources are
saying that about 200 military service
dogs were released in the streets of
kabul
i haven't heard that but it would not
surprise me i saw an image of a bunch of
kennels
really yeah it was pretty disturbing i
couldn't hard to fact check that yeah we
gotta fact check that stuff it's hard
christopher says i feel like at this
point the black swan event is that joe
biden messes up every everything such a
degree that we are all united uniting
would truly be unpredictable i gotta say
man good point right now under you know
you got a lot of populist leftists
who are ragging on joe biden
and the right dragon on joe biden and so
now you have this creepy neocon
establishment democrat alliance which
has been you know been around for a
while but now they've lost a lot of the
populist leftists so now it's starting
to get funny when you see like the
populist left being like i'm going to
buy guns and fighting is terrible and
like we were betrayed everything we
thought we were going to get we didn't
get and i i love it when when biden was
like he didn't meet with black lives
matter or speak with them and they got
really angry about it it's like yo you
thought this guy was going to give you
something meanwhile you did get
everything that you thought you were
going to get you got not trump yeah
there you go congratulations how is
trump doing for you it's doing yeah
there it is
josh oh my gosh says last year the song
sound of silence covered by disturbed
was the song of the dang year my words
fell on deaf ears like silent raindrops
dude ian i want to sing with y'all i
love to sing that would be awesome i
love the sound of silence the the
electric version from simon simon and
garfunkel yeah it's it's a really great
song you know
you listen to the lyrics and i don't
think it applies in any way or for the
most part to today but it kind of feels
like it does you know
well i don't know the lyrics i love that
song that song is so great i was just
bridging her troubled water yesterday
too yeah like a lot of it reminds me of
twitter
really sound of silence well yeah like
the lyrics talking about like people not
actually listening
praying to the neon god they made that's
right you'll notice if you are
completely silent you'll hear
the blood going
in your head right
it's never truly silent it's true
yeah there's that room that's like the
quietest room in the world but
apparently it's so quiet people can't
stand we gotta build something like that
but it's sensory deprivation or
something that's form of it yeah well so
it's a room where you like walk on a
platform and the whole room is like it's
like spikes all around
so that sound is completely absorbed
there's no echo wow i will tell you this
i created uh i had one little recording
studio where i put sound foam everywhere
and it it's almost painful it's the
weirdest experience
like you there there's like it's not
like there's a loud echo where you can
hear your words repeat it back at you
normally but you truly understand sound
reflection once you dampen the whole
room and then it it sounds like you're
it's weird it's a weird feeling your
words seem to have like no weight to
them yeah because they just disappear
instantly like cocooned yeah it's a
creepy feeling that's like vantablack
with light it like sucks up 99 of the
light that would be a cool room to make
a fanta black sound
have you seen vantablack it just looks
flat yeah a black body
yeah just nothing they put they put a
laser on it
has used it for um art projects yeah oh
yeah vantablack sound absorption with
like led lights of different colors
that would be the craziest room ever
we could make like a floating room where
we do that
it should be floating yeah like turns
and stuff it could be like on a
gyroscope it'd be like a gyroscope i
don't know about that because the sound
absorption stuff are like pointed you
know okay but you'd you'd be like
suspended by cables so then you'd go in
and it would be two layers so the inside
room is mounted on you know four corners
and then there's a gap between the outer
room which is suspended on cables
everything's vanta black and then
there's acoustic absorption around the
whole thing so you walk in you'll still
touch right that's why with uh sensory
deformation tanks you're floating uh-huh
so it's you know it's like the water
yeah yeah it's interesting have you used
one of those
no
i want to go we were talking about
building i have wanted to do a sensory
deprivation thing
but i
i think i have trust issues because it's
like that's it how would you
you just cry and lay there and cry and
cry and cry
that's pretty nice all right madison lin
says ian i saw your federal federal
reserve video from 12 years ago did you
ever get the word out like you said you
wanted to oh i think i saw your comment
well i'm getting the word out now
sometimes it takes a little while there
you go oh yeah it's just it's just a
slow burn yeah bruno branowski says
biden's razor never attribute to malice
that which is adequately explained by
unimaginable never-before-seen
incompetence that's sort of my take the
sleepy joe
i just think the experts aren't that
smart i think we have totally misjudged
them think about it they all went to the
best colleges which we now know are
garbage you know
gaiden says tim to correct your timeline
al qaeda wasn't afghanistan before
taliban taliban were the radicalized
next generation that had been living in
exile during the ussr war and were
returning when usar left interesting
well there you go
all right let's see
kyle o'brien brian says i would trade
biden his administration and all the
woke generals for just one of the
service dogs we left behind convention
of states now we can't be governed by
corrupt cowards who hate us that's so
sad i got a daily call our story death
sentence animal rights group goes after
biden administration for allegedly
leaving service dogs behind it's from
the daily caller the british took their
service dogs home
wow as good as them i guess
they're mad at us for really good
reasons we deserve this yeah cheers yeah
apparently our special relationship's on
the rocks
muskie ferret says so we left afghans
aircraft that they were not able to
operate or maintain also we are there
for their natural resources nobody cares
for freedom that is a based super chat
yeah a lot of uh poppy right yeah poppy
seeds or she gave you opium which you
could whoa whoa
no no no it was clearly to make lemon
poppy seeds muffins clearly to re-shoot
the wizard of oz and the scenes
and the poppies again is that what she
did she laid in a big field of poppies
and got she just like totally got
drugged out
she falls asleep yeah that's right but
it's opium from the pop so if the uh so
if the taliban is now going to be making
a whole bunch of heroin dude and our
southern border is wide open are we
about to have a massive no the taliban
bans all that stuff i'm pretty sure
really yeah they like it but they
they'll sell it too they'll sell it
right they'll export it they don't use
it in the country they don't allow that
but they'll allow it to get out i won't
be surprised
all right tin man says i was enlisted in
the marine corps and if you lost your
weapon during training and couldn't be
found they would literally close down
the base until it was then you'd get
njp'd they left yet they left 80 billion
dollars in weapons in afghanistan at
double standard much oh that's beyond a
double standard man yeah that's pretty
bad i love that your name is tin man by
the way after that wizard of oz
daniel morton says tim what do you think
would happen if the u.s pulled all of
its troops out of south korea in 1970
what the u.s just did by pulling out
afghanistan was the modern equivalent
troop presence is deterrence against
aggression
you know i think there's similarities
but i don't think it's the same thing
the uh but there but there are
similarities and that's that's the big
challenge um
yeah this is a moral conundrum i've
brought up before because i'm actually
i'm happy that south korea exists and is
flourishing and and it's growing and
things like that at the same time i
don't like the fact that the u.s gets
involved in all these other people's
business and so
it really is a challenge i think there's
there's it's not so much about a
principle like i believe in free speech
but more so where do you draw the line
on free speech because i can say i'm for
free speech all day and night and then
be like oh but if someone incites
violence and then if you entertain the
idea that the government can pass a law
to say something isn't free speech
because incitement of violence is bad
then someone says okay past the law
saying hate speeches and free speech and
you're like oh okay so maybe we're
either for all free speech even if as
you know whatever you say
or we're okay with the government
putting restrictions therein lies the
big challenge i think everybody butts
into so to answer your question if the
u.s pulled all the trips out of south
korea north korea would have came in
with the soviets and taken over and
there would be no south korea it would
be well i don't know is vietnam how's
vietnam doing i haven't looked in the
politics of vietnam they have a lot of
contracts for manufacturing a lot of
clothes and things are made there so my
way to cambodia actually there was like
a whole treaty with regard to that yeah
so i don't know you know it it is very
difficult but i think um i i think we
should not have entered afghanistan in
the first place like regarding free
speech i agree with that obviously you
can't go out and on tv and and command
people to do violence but like if you're
in your room alone and you say the most
vile illegal stuff you're fine you're in
your room alone if the government's
spying on you and hears you in your room
alone just saying stuff like you're
reading a script you know you're and
you're reading some crazy violent lines
whatever maybe you're not reading a
script it doesn't matter because you're
alone and you're not inciting violence
but it can be taken out of context
if they're if they're spying on you it
can take it out of context i had an idea
for a joke with my friends because we
were playing gta a long time ago like
gta 4
and my one friend was yelling these
really awful things like take it to the
bridge go to the bridge now and i'm like
yo the things you're saying right now
and telling us to do like if we're taken
out of context so i just imagine there's
like some cops in a van and they're
listening and they hear this guy being
like and then we're gonna take the car
drive it underneath the bridge
et cetera et cetera and then the cops
are like it's happening and they break
in and it's something like it's like
three fat dudes playing gta like what's
happening right all out of context
they're going after phone records and
things i mean it's so all that's out of
context
all right race gartner says adding to
ian's point then we should further
assist elon provide internet to the
whole world through the many satellites
side note did you see the military dogs
left in their kennels at the airport
yeah yes yeah internet global internet
that's a big part of it left a bunch of
dogs in the airport yeah i'm not putting
anything past u.s government today
why would they why would they do that
elizabeth carmela comedian
says to add to all the bad news of the
day lake tahoe is currently burning down
here in california i live about two
hours away we've been inundated with
smoke for weeks everyone has been
evacuated from there please give a shout
out to them and pray yeah sad to hear it
i hope everybody's okay
natural disasters man it's scary stuff
it's interesting about that with uh
larry elder who's running against gavin
newsom has brought up the points about
how a lot of these wildfires are due to
poor forestry management yes yeah which
a friend of mine uh sashi mcentee who
was the mayor of mill valley california
has also been saying that these
wildfires are in large part because of
that yeah pg e runs a bunch of old
outdated power lines through the forests
and they're like you know debris and
sticks and and then one of the power
lines would go out and set a forest fire
but i feel like you should be able to
run lines through a forest without
having to worry about the forest being
so poorly managed that you're going to
set the whole state on fire should
something go wrong because i feel like
lines are going to go down right and
then you shouldn't have to worry about
california being so horribly mismanaged
that you're going to burn the whole
state i think they run power lines
underground in some places on earth i
don't know yeah there's lots of places
new york this above ground thing's weird
yeah um listerable says it's so strange
to everyone talk about what potus does
as if his mind was working that's a good
point to be honest
brendan thompson says tim i'm sick of
you lying about my country australia
weekend brendan thompson we can buy
foster's locker here what did i say
brandon yeah oh there's brandon i think
he said right now i'm just shouting out
brennan oh okay you can buy fosters what
do you guys think of jacinda ardern
i'm a little weird at outbuyer she's
totally weird she seems kind of
authoritative really and she also had a
thing after the christ church shooting
she had a call which he called the
christ church call to try and get all
western nations to uh
censor internet speech that's crazy i i
was working at mines while that was
going on and facilitating some of the
boost admin stuff and people keep kept
posting the video of the christchurch
shooter first person video and then
they'd like overlay the doom console and
it was like a video game like how many
people you could shoot in the head
so disturbing but but i mean i it was
very it messed me up it changed me to
see that over and over so i understand i
understand censoring
you know you got to protecting the young
mind that's like a that's what this is
all about i think the censorship thing
all right let's see
lucy lurker says brandon burns in las
vegas is working to stage a protest on
september 7th for a mass call out with a
rally in las vegas and elsewhere freedom
of choice rally he has a good take and
would be a great guest to have on i went
i i google searched vaccine mandate
protest and i'm pretty sure you can find
every single city like just name a city
it was like roswell new mexico dubuque
cedar rapids not dubuque but you know
cedar rapids and it was just like i had
a list of like 30 and i'm like i can't
even fit this in my browser so i had to
get rid of some of them and i was like i
read that in my main segment like
protest protest protest approach people
and it's a lot of healthcare workers too
that's right there's a lot of nurses and
stuff yeah saying nah which is
interesting too because we have such a
huge nursing shortage and we're willing
to just have a worse nursing shortage
yep this is it hundreds gather in santa
monica to protest hundreds protests in
in new york protests in greece get
violent like this is like mainstream
this should be of course you're not
going to see it on cnn yeah you don't
see it yep you don't see it unless
something violent what what flag to the
guy in santa monica
wave it looks like the the lgbtq
i don't know it's purple
there's there's a photo don't worry i've
always got the gasoline that's right but
it's it's a rainbow
i love it
absolutely
hey man rainbow flag with the gadsden
flag when it comes to my body i call the
shots and then it shows the shot
i love the gadsden pride flag that's
cool don't tread on me
the gadsden flag beautiful in many forms
have you ever seen have you seen the
antifa uh total fascist one where it
says you know we will tread and it's
it's a snake being squeezed by the the
fist i have not seen that not pretty yep
they march around with it it's it's red
and black which is funny because like
they're claiming to be anarchists who
are going to force people who are
libertarians like what that's right yeah
these people are creepy weirdos
and max says libby emin's quote from the
last show new york artists have been
co-opted by authoritarianism at this
point it's propaganda do exactly as
you're told they create the type of work
that they are told
yeah yeah there you go
and so so where do you live libby dude
come on you can do it all right let's
see
chaos eternum says truckers join the
fight australia and u.s drivers are
organizing to protest and am optimistic
we will win this game of chicken spread
the word you guys rock truckers nice
there's a trucker shortage have you guys
seen that
that's why gas prices
yeah that's a disaster that's a big
thing okay there's a huge problem too
because uh most of the truckers are like
55 or older
and they're not getting any new people
in
to the to the business and once
once we don't have anyone to deliver our
crap to us like
what are we gonna do we're not gonna
have any stuff we're not gonna have any
food
cole will says love tim's non-stop
reporting on current events but we need
solutions one is removing the need for
fiat and central bank investing
what is ian's opinion on block fi and d5
or celsius network and btc after mining
is over um well block buy holds your
crypto for you they'll pay you interest
on it but you don't actually have the
money while they're while they're
holding it um the other stuff d5 what is
that decentralized uh finance finance
yeah it's a whole movement called d5 and
that's like the decentralized finance
movement and bitcoin mining ends in like
100 years or something i don't know yeah
eventually and then it's gonna be proof
of um proof of stake as opposed to proof
of work um where like just the fact that
you have the money allows you to get
more money i think they'll fork bitcoin
something will happen there will be a
vote it'll fork into something slightly
different and they'll then you'll get
centralized takeover you asked a lot of
a lot of questions about a lot of
different things but i agree with you
that solutions and uh new technologies
is is where we're going and we're
building new shows on the team cast
network about that specifically so
that's why we have the cass castle vlog
rolling with uh we're just about hitting
daily videos the goal is
to not just to be always so negative but
you take a look at some of the prominent
creators like on youtube and where
they've gone and they're like legit pro
establishment shills like you don't even
gotta think you can just do the
government tells you to do you know it's
like no we're gonna make fun videos
where we like you know ride around on
motorcycles and there's chickens and you
know we race cars and jump over the roof
and then we're gonna have a gadsden flag
saying think for yourself and live free
i want to build a solar-powered water
condenser on the property if possible
they work more in the desert though so
it might not oh it's so humid here you'd
fill up 100 gallons an hour interesting
yeah we'd be like we're supposed to do
those water you
drink
condensed
that's a cool idea that's really easy to
do yeah yeah you just just put it
outside and you like the water
condensers different yeah i'll show you
the plan honestly we could just do a
standard um
water condenser where you do like a
really big net with like the sheets oh
those are great those fog catchers yeah
exactly and the water just drips down
yeah i mean we when we had a mini ramp
outside every morning we'd get like two
gallons of water on it
and it was really annoying except to go
out and sweep it all off just from this
good vlog
but i was thinking like what if we took
the skate light material which is a it's
it's a it's a plastic wood kind of like
resin of some sort it's like no it's
like a resin wood chip mix and what if
we just put those up and just funnel
them down we'd you get so much water
every morning it's insane so we don't
even need solar powered yeah not here
those are for deserts the solar ones
yeah yeah where you yeah
that's what i think our military should
be doing is building water for people
around the earth wells and things like
that i mean if we build these artificial
water capture devices we could probably
reclaim desert oh yeah maybe water into
it at the very least we can be like yo
we're not the bad guys anymore
all right
let's see uh butt grubber says tim the
state of washington is firing hundreds
of employees in the state police alone
of the vaccine mandate while taking away
their retirement and unemployment
benefits look up trooper lemay on jason
rantz podcast
yeah i was talking to a friend
and just like a normie and then i was
just like
what they're doing with the uh vaccine
managed with no medical exemptions is
nightmarish and like not nazism and she
was just like that's not happening it
has happened yeah how am i gonna what's
happening like prove it i'm like here's
me
doing the reporting and appearing on fox
news prime time telling everybody that
new york did this
you know it's like you gotta just google
search man that's a thing too where
people don't want to
see that the thing is happening that
they don't want to have happening so
they just assume that it's not because
it's illogical it's like not checking
your bank account balance because you
don't want to be out of money right
that's that's a clever trick doesn't
work i'm going to try that one next time
next time
neil williams says tim mentioning
electric dreams is the equivalent of joe
rogan mentioning dmt on the podcast no i
think marvel references yeah well star
trek it's been stargate as of lately oh
yeah yeah but i mentioned electric
dreams i think five times did you watch
stargate i've never really got into it
i've missed a bunch i probably i've
probably seen like 150 episodes out of
the 200 and something should i like
start at the beginning and watch it it's
really good watch the movie um movie
first did you see the movie
movie is really the the show starts off
based on the movie
but it's it's different it's like
there's different there's plot points
different actors like the plot is
different like we're into track but i've
seen oh you'll love stargazing now
i think it's so much better let me let
me just i don't want to spoil too much
but it is like a super old show
stargate starts off with like modern
military just you know like oh look we
got the stargate to these other planets
and these other galaxies and it ends
with humans adopting all this crazy-ass
technology and now they have beaming
like they develop well they they get
technology from other races that they
trade with and so it's cool to see
humans go from
kinetic weapons just by luck having a
stargate that allows them to interact
with more advanced technological you
know species to having warp capabilities
building the ships going to war and then
becoming one of the dominant species in
the galaxy it's pretty cool
that's cool that's awesome james spader
you familiar with his work yeah he's the
scientist in the movie no way he's so
good my problem with the tv show was i
felt like we were missing a james spader
well you're always missing james spader
when he's not around yeah man shout out
to james speaker i love him
all right let's see we got here jonathan
aylmer says tim icu nurses at sydney's
prince alfred and st vincent hospitals
are blowing the whistle that patients
are being sedated to safely control them
whoa
i haven't heard any of that that sounds
crazy if it's true though okay as a
point of reference too sedation is a
technique that is commonly used in
hospitals to keep people from removing
ivs from injuring themselves falling on
the floor i used to sit with people who
were being sedated
to make sure they're still breathing
make sure they were pulling ivs out and
coming undone from their um
bondage equipment this is an important
one
finkenfarn says hey tim and crew how is
the forensic analysis of the freedom
phone going keep it the good work your
voices give hope around the world i
think it's just a matter of buying them
yeah we have the the people who are
gonna we we know who's gonna be doing
the analysis on them and now we just
need to get them shipped out okay
tomorrow you guys are checking those
things out yeah we want to ian's got
like a list of like he's got a crack
group team yeah tech wizards good
developers are working on the fetaverse
project okay shred this thing and then
integrate our software into it for
future cool future mods gonna be great
cool so we'll we'll get that we'll get
that shipped out
all right
let's see
so a lot of people are saying that i'm
wrong about the fda letter
hondo says tim fajr says they are
legally distinct i've read both letters
eua and the bla until it's packaged with
the legal disclaimer two items can be
identical and packaged differently right
i'm i'm just wondering what the what the
argument is for for a legal distinction
and and how is how is that relevant to
saying that the vaccine isn't fda
approved when it's the exact same thing
but you're arguing a brand you know what
i mean like they're legally distinct i
get it
is it is it an issue of the emergency
authorization and like liability or
something
i don't know
they're the same they're the same exact
vaccine same exact vaccine just one's
got a different name let's get to the
bottom of this so apparently something's
inaccurate
well i guess they're saying that
there is the fi the pfizer bioentec
vaccine
and the community vaccine which are
identical in every way except their
legally distinct products
and one of them got fda approved the
other one did not but they're identical
right i see and they can be used
interchangeably oh okay that's what that
the letter so okay but i so i don't
so technically it's not fda approved but
it can be used interchangeably with the
one that is
i but i think that's kind of semantics
you know what i mean yes like the fda is
saying like this formulation it's good
to go it's weird that that happened i
don't know whatever i think you know as
per usual don't take medical advice from
wackos on the internet we're just
internet people talking to cameras you
know
i'm not your lawyer i'm not your
financial advisor i'm not your friend
i'm not your foe okay i'm just kidding
find your own lawyer that was find your
own investment
find your own doctor talk to them and
get sound advice i i do think when it
comes to all of this stuff there's a few
things i should say legal advice is
never really an issue on podcasts i
guess but when people do legal shows but
when it comes to finance and when it
comes to medical stuff get off the
internet you know why
i get we get super chats all the time
from people saying like hey tim big fan
of the show you just wanted to shout out
the hard work you're doing and mention
that you know brn crypto is the number
one currency and everyone should okay
dude i just made i don't even know like
no dude people are always trying to do
some kind of social media thing to like
pump and dump yeah and then the same
thing is true like
there's there's a lot of people who are
posting things with confirmation bias or
cultural issues just
make sure you talk to people you know
and trust because the internet is a
crazy place full of crazy people that's
why i'm like the vlog is so important
the cast castle stuff because it's like
really you're gonna see people who have
the principles of freedom like like you
know andy's wearing a rothbard shirt
while he's skating
but it's not a show about politics it's
not like we're gonna be preaching to you
about what you should it's just gonna be
like inspiring you to be a better person
have fun get some optimism
making good news fun news you know the
dog running around and the chickens are
flapping and jumping and just you know
dude me and carter were playing music
earlier carter banks he's our uh he's
our resident uh orchestrator yeah new
producer magnificent musician man did it
sound good
cody mcnutt says i have a gadsden prides
flag hat patch it really confuses people
i love it
absolutely
all right let's see we'll do a couple
more here
the survival preppers say the vax
mandate is a purge of those who don't
align with the promoted narrative
hundreds and thousands of people are
going to be fired who will they be
replaced by if you're not prepping
already it's a good time to get started
thanks tim and crew do you guys see this
thing on facebook where it's like
somebody posted something about canning
like like making jam and beans and then
putting it in the can
and facebook has like a warning i
haven't confirmed it but people have
tweeted it out saying
does it feel like someone is becoming
too prepared notify you know you know
look for the signs of extremism that's
insane i saw a couple different posts
i i don't i haven't confirmed it
but we all saw the thing on facebook
where it was like you may have been
exposed to extremist content my favorite
my favorite was that you know the meme
of the of like the the you know the the
shifty eyed you know guy
and it said when all of your friends get
notifications about extremist content
but you don't
it's you
you're doing it
all right let's see
riley anderson says hey tim fellow
beanie guy here can you explain why you
consider yourself left-wing libertarian
and more importantly where you disagree
with modern republicans that classifies
you left libertarian well republican
doesn't necessarily mean libertarian or
whatever republicans tend to be like i
would say overwhelmingly moderate
conservative leaning towards um
uh
what's the right way to put it
classically liberal not colloquially
liberal like the actual truman of
liberal as opposed to libertarian but
left libertarian is basically like
hippies living on a farm where i
disagree with republicans is probably on
like
i'm i'm less free-market capitalism than
many republicans i'm in favor of social
programs the problem i always mention
though is that idealistically it's
really easy to be like we should all
cooperate and have certain system in
place that have certain guarantees like
i love the fact the fire department
exists i love firefighters they're
fantastic i like the idea of the armed
forces and these things are
you you you you you know it's it's a
government service it's a guarantee and
i think there's good reasons to have
them
so the issue is basically like on the
left and right scale of the political
compass
the right is where you start getting
into more and more free cap free market
capitalism the left is where you get
more and more into
what's the right way to put it um
cooperative systems so um
it's it's it's hard to actually break
down but the simplest way to explain it
is left libertarian would be like 10
hippies living on a farm or a small
tribe of 30 people that come to
agreements a family i think jack murphy
mentioned this a family is communist
there's a guy who's the father and the
mother they're in charge they control
things they delegate responsibilities
the children just have to they're told
what they're provided for and that makes
sense at a really small level so left
libertarian is like hey i'm not going to
tell you what to do but if you want to
come hang out pitch in around the house
we got pizza we got beers it doesn't
work when you go into multiple cities
because now one city is like that's not
fair that we do this work and you get
that and then you start needing better
systems of of economics so the way i
usually say it is
idealistically i'm left libertarian
realistically i'm like socially liberal
so i'm like centrist you know slightly
left leaning on some policies i'd love
for there to be universal healthcare
within this system i don't know if this
system is free of corruption to the
point where we could actually have it so
i'll leave it at that
go make sure you smash the like button
um you have to
uh ian's life depends on it oh and gonna
go to timcast.com
then go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up for all of you who are
members share the show with your friends
give us a good review you can follow the
show at tim cast irl all over the place
where we post clips and you can follow
me personally at timcast on you know
twitter or whatever and mines and stuff
like that uh do you want to shout
anything out libby uh yeah you can find
me at libby evans on twitter and i'm at
the post millennial and you should check
us out you can also follow me at ian
crossland on mines and at twitter and
everywhere else and ian crossland.net
catch you later
and you guys are more than welcome to
follow me on twitter at sour patch lids
i am approaching sour patch kids and
that is my goal in life so please help
me out with my goal
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for the special members only
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you